Yeah.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe,
what does that mean?
God,
170 fucking episodes and I'm still keeping my laptop power on.
It's ridiculous.
Um,
we brought to you by the flashlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link entering the code name,
Rogan,
and a,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toys for men.
It was a tight race between number one and number two.
What was the other one?
Ham.
Melons.
We sliced ham.
Whatever it is,
do it or don't do it.
They're just a sponsor folks.
But it's a good product if you're into masturbating,
if you're going to do it,
and you probably are,
this is better than just doing it.
It's technology.
Okay.
Embrace the times.
We were also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com oh and it makers of Alpha
brain,
and we have a new alpha brain that's coming out.
It's called Alpha brain source for all you folks in the UK that have much more
restrictive laws when it comes to nutritional supplements.
Like they can't even get vitamin B six over there and some in some places in
Europe.
That's right.
The strange rent.
Yeah.
So our Alpha brain was considered a drug,
so it takes it out.
Does it put anything else in?
No.
Well it's just different.
The alternative ingredients that have a similar effects and so we're still
fucking with it right now.
Hipster ingredients.
It's,
you know,
it might be better for some people that find the original Alpha brain is hard to
take.
Like some people get nauseous from it and some people doesn't make them feel
good.
It's,
it's,
it's real weird.
Everybody has a different,
everybody has a different biological setup,
you know,
I feel like I was a little sensitive to it.
Yeah.
But I took a lot that was the issue take too much.
And I took two in the morning,
two at night and I think that was too much.
Three once in one dose,
three or four in one dose or forgotten.
And I did not feel good.
And I was like,
maybe this is what people feel like all the time.
Everybody's got a different tolerance for caffeine,
for anything.
But for me too is good.
I take two Alpha brains and it's uh,
it's just,
it's not that shit from that movie.
What is it with Bradley Cooper?
It's just vitamins that enhance cognitive function.
It's all,
it is enhance.
Just like vitamins enhance your health.
It's very subtle but effective.
I enjoy it.
And the most important thing about any of the Onnit products is there's a
hundred percent money back guarantee.
You don't have to return the product.
Just say it didn't work for you and you get all your money back.
And we tried to make this thing as fair as possible.
If you think it's too expensive,
I urge you please,
if you're interested in nootropics to go online,
Google the subject,
look into it.
There's a lot of interesting studies behind it and I personally have been
studying them and experimenting with it for a long time now and I like it.
I liked the effects and if you think that that on it,
Alpha brain is too expensive,
go to the website and steal the ingredient list.
Just look at it's all online.
The exact amounts were online.
Go buy in bulk and make your own stuff and I hope it works.
I swear to God,
I am way more concerned with people not feeling ripped off than I am up for
making money.
That's why we make it as easy as possible.
100% money back guarantee too.
Don't forget that,
so enjoy it or don't enjoy it,
but there's a bunch of cool products that we have out
now.
One of them is called shroom tech sport and it's excellent for anybody who's
really into working out.
If you're really in,
if you do anything that's like super strenuous,
you know you're,
you know you're doing running or like some serious weightlifting class or
something like that.
Anything you do will you really exert yourself.
It's an amazing supplement.
It's great for Jujitsu.
I love it for,
for any kind of athletic stuff,
but if you're not in the work in Alec,
Bryan doesn't even take that shit.
Doesn't help.
Yo-Yoing does this doesn't help us.
Yoyo Games.
We also have a shroom tech.
What would the shrimp tech is based on all the information that's at [inaudible]
dot com [inaudible] dot com but it's based on the quarter steps mushroom,
which is a mushroom that actually enhances your body's ability to process oxygen
and people like,
and a higher climates and animals in higher climates eat it and they actually
get energy and they,
that's how they figured out that this stuff works.
Um,
we also have a shroom tech immune,
which is a,
an immune supplement.
And basically the way this one works,
what as it's been explained to me is your body doesn't understand what this
mushroom is when it thinks it may be like a bug thinks you may be sick,
so your body's immune system fires up for a fight that never comes.
Right?
And so then your immune system is just like on full tilt,
you know,
it's,
it pumps it up,
which it's a really,
I'm,
I'm real into probiotics.
I drink Kombucha tea every day.
I take Acidophilus,
um,
I take live cultures.
That's why cutters and ever get sick cutters and like people that can throw
stuff themselves and their body thinks they're dying.
So really it didn't make sense.
I guess that would be amazing match if that's what you get up to do.
We would never get sick.
Just give yourself a little cut every day.
Yeah,
I don't think it works out.
Let me try it.
Yeah.
Um,
we also have a new mood,
which is a five HTP supplement,
which is a little serotonin booster.
And uh,
again,
like I said,
please study all this stuff online.
100% money back guarantee.
Always end.
Right now you have a special coupon,
don't you?
I saw what the fuck is that even stand for the special coupon is worth,
it's 2012 so it's 20.2 12%
20 point 12% law.
But what was the coupon code?
Actually I was trying to figure it out.
I was like,
like I said,
and it's in,
well I'll tell you right now it's,
and why are sending like 20 years Rogan's I dunno.
What the fuck is stands for?
Not Your New Year,
New Year maybe it's like texting,
like tech speak.
Yeah.
It's probably something that kids like do.
And we're like old man,
like let and Ayi.
Yeah.
These kids these days.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
I dunno.
Let me,
let me make sure I get the,
the,
the actual thing right.
I got it somewhere.
He should never young guns now.
Never.
Dammit.
I should have this right in front of me,
but I don't,
it's not your tweeter.
I know what I can't find it.
Tweet that shit.
And why are and why our 2012 or just 12,012 no,
Nyer 12 that's it.
And why are 12 wow,
we're organized as fuck.
Sorry.
Well that's the end of these stupid commercials,
right?
Go to Joe Rogan battling that.
Click the link and read and decode named Rogan get 10% but don't do that.
Do the
other one and why are get yourself 20 point 12% off.
That's it.
It's over.
And that was,
it was brutal for me too.
All right gentlemen and ladies and everybody else that's tuning in.
Peter Joseph is here.
You get to the bottom of shit.
[inaudible]
we're going to get to the obvious shit.
First of all,
before we even started this interview,
I want to tell you that I'm ready to join your cult.
I've gone online,
I've,
I've seen other cult members and leaders before.
They're not nearly as charismatic as you.
They don't make as much sense as you,
I think you're on point and I'm ready to sign up.
You just tell me what I need to.
Uh,
you're,
you're a utopian view of the perfect society is fucking brilliant,
man.
It's a,
it's,
it's dead on Peter Joseph.
You don't know is the creative,
it's like I used the,
the or the original movie and then all these followup movies and now it's
actually,
you know,
you refer to it as a movement and that's not cocky in any way,
shape or form.
That's just what it is.
It's a movement,
you know,
so the zeitgeists movement that,
Tz em on Twitter,
that Tz movement on Twitter,
um,
and it's,
a,
a fascinating thing that's going on right now.
And your movies and your movement,
I mean,
can you say it's yours now?
Now it's sort of like it's become a life of its own right?
No owns it.
And,
and whether people like it or not,
they're a part of the zeitgeists movement one way or another.
What does the zeitgeists movement?
It's the definition of the times.
It's the cultural nuance of Ivy.
This is all the shit that we believe and think it's true and how we progress
through time.
Hence the Zike guys movement.
So whether we,
anyone likes it or not,
they're part of the Zeitgeists boob.
So I just brought that into that particular context.
How did you become this smooth talk bad motherfucker?
How did this happen?
How did you become this guy?
Because it's not just that you have all these great ideas.
It's a,
you never use the word awesome.
All right.
You just sail through the sentences and you're just like your musician.
Is that what your background is?
I am a musician with percussionists,
classical percussionists.
That's what I tried to do for years and years,
but didn't fit in the whole orchestral establishment percussion scene.
Now,
Brett percussion in enlightened me exists.
It's not just,
it's not drunk.
It's drums.
You have the mallet family,
then there's the kettle drums like Timpani.
Then you have hand portion and learn the mall as much as I could.
Given the time that I have in my studio in Culver City,
I have full section of my little house blocked off or whenever I can pursue my
old hobby again,
which seems to be less and less.
Unfortunately.
People listen to me.
Some of your stuff online,
so I'm,
I'm working on compiling.
I've been hesitant to do that because my identity has been so bizarre as a
filmmaker,
which I'd never intended to be.
Actually,
I think I sent you the link of the first Zike guys performance a performance.
It wasn't intended to be a documentary in the sense formulaically as you would
traditionally assumed,
which is how did it morph?
What happened?
Well,
I had the 2007 I did a six night run in lower Manhattan free,
who was a thing.
I spent a lot of money on prepared this piece over the course of seven months.
Didn't expect it to go anywhere because basically I had no rights to actually
pursue this as a film.
So this is a firm firmly one shot off,
fair use type of deal.
So I did it,
publicized it,
people came,
everything was cool,
everyone liked it.
It was very dramatic.
He has some people walked out and people really liked it.
Some inspired Q.
And.
A.
It was a catharsis for me.
I was in advertising,
I was doing shit that I didn't appreciate doing is what the system does,
you know,
it forces you into a particular pocket for the most of us for a lot of,
we don't necessarily enjoy what we're doing.
So this is a catharsis.
And the unique thing about it is it was so honest.
This is a very honest work from me.
I didn't really think about approaching a demographic.
And when I,
when it went online on Google video before youtube,
this is when Google video was the only Internet video site that actually had
full length stuff.
And very rarely you'd hear about feature length films getting there.
And I just happened to hit that paradigm right then and it went crazy viral and
the lawsuits were threatened and everyone thought it was some big documentary,
big production.
They had no idea that background of lawsuits or threaten the people that are in
it.
You know,
that film was a fair use film.
It was not intended to be released.
So whenever people saw like 20,
30 million views in the first year of when seeing dollar signs as though,
and I wasn't even selling anything,
I wasn't intending to.
And then eventually I went back,
you know,
the tail between my legs with all these people that,
cause the whole thing is full.
The whole thing is a montage of the zeitgeists.
It's just one big cluster of all sorts of different personalities kind of mushed
together.
And most of them supported it.
And then some of them got a little greedy but everyone got paid off for the most
part.
And there's still a few rocks left unturned,
but the statute of limitations is now up on that.
So if anyone wants to sue me,
you're going to have the greater,
uh,
effect the ass.
Yeah.
Well it isn't all just stuff that is out there in the public record.
Essentially.
It is,
but you know,
and put it together.
Anybody can sue anybody for anything if they think they can get money out of it.
Especially in the film and the film and media industry.
So you obviously you surprised by the response to the first film you,
you had no idea any of this was going to happen.
I had no intention to make a second film.
I never considered myself a filmmaker.
It was always musically driven and then a denim came out in 2008 and that was,
that was picked up by the art of his film festivals shown here at the Egyptian
theater.
That had a huge response.
Even larger in a certain sense because it was the first time it had been
publicly displayed,
this whole phenomenon and then that carried over into the zeitgeists movement,
which was basically the,
the thought experiment I had is like,
okay,
we have these film series.
He had plenty of people like Michael Moore and making films.
Do they really support change or are they really doing anything to actually
initiate a community effort to get something going?
And at that point in time,
I had no idea what that would actually be.
It was I did,
I,
I figured,
well it says in the movie on if he remembers,
I coasted end up,
it says join the movement,
start the largest critical mass the world's ever seen to try and get some change
going and it seemed to take root.
And then from there it's been this kind of bubbling,
changing and morphine kind of phenomenon that's global.
Now the zeitgeists movement,
which is,
which is a shared community.
I want to make people understand it isn't like a movement than any the world's
ever seen.
This is just the people that the group of people would have a similar value set.
That's the only way I describe it.
It's the ultimate anti institution.
So I often don't even reference the movement.
I referenced the ideas behind it.
So you make this documentary,
it gets out and then all the sudden you realize that there's this crazy movement
behind it.
And how do you attempt to organize it?
How do you attempt,
do you not do just get out of its way and let it organize itself?
Like sort of an occupy Wall Street types of it.
Combination of the two.
We started off at a self organizing capacity but volunteers from around the
world,
it was beautiful actually just getting all this communication from different
demographics.
I mean the whole is like our spectrum.
The audience if you will,
for not just the fillings with for the movement that it paid attention to these
ideas is totally vast.
Yet people that are,
I've met kids that are like 10 years old with a little zeitgeists move a tee
shirt on up to 80 year old men that you know,
they're looking for something different so it's amazing.
And the ethnicity differences are massive.
Want to be in Israel next month giving a lecture.
It's truly unique.
So it self organized.
As it began we started to pinpoint different coordination positions.
People in charge
places and give lectures as well.
I do.
And what is like,
what is the,
the lecture essentially,
uh,
is it just you breaking down how this got started or is it you talk about yeah,
your perspective while they usually it's lectures broken into three released now
lecture,
spoken to three typical lectures broken into the first part being what defines
awareness and logic.
And reason how we think about information.
We're dismissing the Messenger.
Gotta look at it logically.
X,
Y,
and Z's.
Forget,
forget the subjects.
It's all about the train of thought that the process of thought is,
is irrespective of personality.
There's a huge conflict in society between logic and psychology and they're
very,
very different and I can expand on that as we go.
Second Section is the criticism of the current socioeconomic platform,
which I consider to be one massive corruption.
We talk about corruption.
You'll a hard drive corrupts.
It's messed up or criminal,
political and Rob's a convenience store.
It's a corruption of the system,
the socioeconomic system,
the legal system.
To me,
the entire socioeconomic system,
namely economic,
not only politics,
politics is an outgrowth,
but I won't jump on that.
One is a is one massive corruption of what it means to live on this planet,
what it means to perfect good public health.
So there's that section he had stay in Ed.
That's massive and it must the criticisms and presentations I do.
Then there's the solution which support the train of thought,
which has many different names as far as a new social system,
which I don't even really address any more.
I'd just like to go for the train of thought.
And what it comes down to is you have to have a system,
a system that's based on planetary resource management,
very fundamental stuff.
By the way,
a system that's not based on growth and all the strange,
infinite growth paradigm stuff.
I'm sure my resource manager,
whole community,
one giant community gets together and says,
okay,
what do we need and how do we keep everybody happy
globally,
globally?
And you think about it in the broadest symbiotic sense.
You know,
like one of the great psychological revelations,
intellectual revelations that we've had as species is that is that we've been
living in these divisive kind of tribalistic concepts and we assume normality
with it because of how long they persisted.
But we tend to find that what we find now as far as information is concerned,
is that we live in a global system.
We live in a symbiosis.
There's stretches outward,
honest to infinity.
So the very idea of separation because literally tangibly on applicable to the
way we approach our life,
where we approached knowledge,
the way we approach approach society,
the way we approach economics,
which is the defining feature of our existence.
You know,
how we get what we need,
how we relate,
of course,
how it,
the renewable elements,
the regeneration,
if you will,
the Omni regeneration or as a Buckminster fuller of everything.
How do we respect that?
And the ultimate realization is that we have to begin to unify all concepts.
You see this and intellectual things.
Consilience is a book by Edward O.
Wilson.
Early on in the 1980s he wrote about this concept of all the the disciplines
starting to merge together.
So you can't talk about chemistry without talking about biology or other way
around.
You can't talk about physics that are talking about mathematics.
You can't separate anything anymore.
And that's a unique phenomenon that's occurring and you can stretch that train
of thought backwards and forwards in my approach as far as simplicity,
the economic system has to be unified.
It has to have a very simple respect of what actually supports us.
I can ramble that.
How did that transition take place?
We need,
even if you were to engineer the perfect Utopian mathematic formula for keeping
everybody no such thing,
what do you do with the money that you have now?
Does it just dissolved?
We start from scratch,
like,
you know,
how does that work?
How does it transition from,
from one monetary system that makes no sense.
Where there's massive amounts of corruption and people with huge amounts of
resources that they've probably gotten by.
What would be considered immoral,
although legal ways.
Sure.
What do you do with their money?
Well,
there's a few few answers to that one.
Let's,
let's get rid of the word that Utopian though.
I mean,
I don't mean that in a sense of a fantasy that's impossible of being achieved.
it is an ideal like a boulder,
Colorado.
As far as what friend of mine said to me once,
it's a working utopia and I believe it is,
you know,
I don't mean it in a sense of impossible.
Okay.
You put utopia is a touchy word.
I like the word sometimes it's just missed is finite
only the best that we know up until now and the great flaws that we're not
actually doing anything based on the knowledge we have today.
But to answer your question,
how do we do that?
You know,
how do we transition?
The system is failing.
You have an unemployment crisis,
we have a debt crisis and we have a,
um,
and we have a energy crisis that's looming.
Three of the nails in the coffin as far as I'm concerned,
that interweave in certain ways.
We also have another crisis.
And that crisis is the way people raise children.
We have the crisis of,
you know,
too many people that don't give a fuck about their kids and they're raising
these little problems,
these people that are,
you know,
and the crisis of consciousness means for sure.
And that absolutely transmits from parent to children.
You know,
when,
when they're not paying attention to the kids or where they're bad parenting or
you know,
whatever they have.
Well that brings up the,
he gets the same sort of,
it's like how do we change?
They're there.
How do we change society at the Cork is really,
you got to get to them too.
That's a big percentage of people that are impoverished and uneducated and strip
clubs.
It's great for a lot of things.
It's great for porn too.
Yeah.
Just we want a lot of chaos,
you know,
and you want a lot of messy things.
Great for fighting too.
Um,
but I think that's,
that's a big problem,
right?
I mean,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Hence the nature of what the zeitgeists wound that really defines itself as me.
You can talk about these solution oriented things,
but really it's the,
it's the evolution of human awareness.
The real crisis is the crisis of ignorance.
There's no energy crisis.
It's really just a crisis of misunderstanding what we're doing
and the fact that people have become addicted to the money that's going around
the,
the people that are taking money from corporations,
it's,
it stopped becoming a matter of whether or not it's a good thing.
It's,
it's precedented.
There's a precedent.
It's already in place.
They're making the money.
They're going to continue to make the money and then want to make the money.
And so anything where you say,
well,
hey man,
I don't think that what we're doing is really fair.
I mean,
we're being unfairly influenced by corporations.
Uh,
dude,
we're making this fucking money.
We've been making this money,
we're going to continue to make this money.
You don't just stop,
you know,
it's,
it's very difficult.
Dot.
That's why the failure is so important,
if you will.
The failure that's an on hand is not going to,
is not going to be altered by any new legislations or any fail safes the
establishment might have.
There's no way this system can persist for a number of different reasons I could
throw out there,
first of all,
the of occupy movement,
right?
Everyone says maybe that at this point in time,
the division of,
of rich versus poor is more than it ever was.
Actually.
It's not.
It's always been structurally classed.
There's a structural classes and built into this system occupies only been the
first to really acknowledged that on the global scale of a,
a,
uh,
an issue that's been there from the very beginning because every element of this
system supports that annex getting worse.
We live in a plutonomy now there's more money moving amongst the upper five
percentile influencing GDP.
So much money that it makes the lower percentiles movements and money
irrelevant.
So on it from a firmly economic standpoint,
the lower classes are literally irrelevant to the function of the economy.
Therefore to the,
to the powers that be,
if you will,
to the corporate establishment and to the taxation fueling and big business that
fuels all government.
And this is all because the system has been manipulated.
Yeah,
no,
this
is because the system is intrinsically flawed base based on the need for
differential advantage and an old form of tribalism,
psychological tribalism that you have to gain advantage over.
Others is socially Darwinistic view and what's unique.
Even though I hold that to be self evident and true to the human condition,
if we're,
if we were both existing and extreme scarcity and we had nothing to eat,
we end up finding each other most likely to survive.
That's a natural human instinct.
What's happened now though is that the,
I'm jumping ahead here but following me is that the entire infrastructure of
society,
the human population is so large,
their industry has become so big.
We have the Fukushima meltdown,
we have the nuclear weapons,
we have nano weapons that are on the horizon.
What we have now is we can't have the risk of this type of mentality being the
forefront of our psychology.
We can't have the self betterment of the individual to be the forefront of us
because it goes against our longterm evolutionary fitness,
which means the entire species at risk.
So to put it in a sentence,
the self interest that tends to dominate now that's that really is the
psychological fuel of all the motivations that you see.
The greed,
if fuel's degrees,
just an extension of the,
the basic motivation is really no such thing as greed.
It's just they're in the system.
All of that that you see is going to fuck us all up until we begin to realize
that we can't operate this way cause it's going to destroy us.
Does that make sense?
We nuclear war was the best example.
They don't,
you don't need passports to a CEO.
The fallout,
you know,
nuclear winter would have taken over the entire planet.
If the U S and uh,
Russia went to nuclear war,
even a minor war,
it would have destroyed almost the entire human species.
And a few scientists realize that said,
you know what?
This isn't really a partisan or a country or nationalist issue anymore.
This is a life issue.
So the greater our technology,
the greater our ability,
the greater vulnerability we have.
And the more clear it becomes how we have to unify and make our self interest
become social interest if we intend to survive as a species.
And this is the great paradigm shift of all human thought.
So what do you do with all the weapons?
Well,
you get rid of them,
dismantle them and hope you can regurgitate them into something defective.
Imagine if we were to take over the Pentagon and use their equipment for
monitoring the earth's resources.
Use the amazing surveillance equipment to actually have a productive use.
It would be incredible.
I think everything you say is brilliant and I agree with it 100% but when I
think about it being implemented in today's society,
I think of the human beings that exist right now and how they've been running
their lives based on greed,
real greed based on real ignorance,
based on violence.
I mean you're going to get these people and everybody is going to go hold hands
and sing Kumbaya together.
You know?
I feel like there has to be something,
you know there,
there has to be some sort of event that unites people.
There's not going to be a stopping of the separation of rich and poor.
The rich are only going to get richer and smaller and smaller.
And when,
if you want to see anger,
just wait.
Just wait.
Where are we?
Haven't even touched the anger stage as it were.
When you say that is what's going to start the initial transition into something
new and the point of the movement really is not to try to initiate some step by
step logical transition to assume human beings are rational and they're just
going to say,
oh,
that sounds better.
That sounds more efficient now that that's not the way the human being works at
all,
at least at this stage.
So the failure will happen is like I said,
movements on the sidelines as far as I'm concerned,
trying to spread information about what a new social system may be exposing the
roots of this system and as this tipping point occurs,
those that are on the outs will slowly become on the end and you'll have a very
powerful large,
complicated revolution that will happen one way or another.
I had this and it's an inevitability to me,
so all the rich 1.0% doesn't matter.
Many billions of dollars they have the police are not going to protect them.
There's going to be a very unique unpredictable shift in the human social
structure.
It's a fucking movie,
isn't it?
It is.
Isn't it an a movie?
I mean really a great time in the movie of its time when things get really
exciting.
I've said about the occupy movement that to me,
they're like white blood cells.
They don't know exactly why they're there,
but they know that there's an issue and they've the immune system,
there's a beer,
there's a sickness here.
Social Disorder.
It's a social immune system response.
It really is.
I mean they just clogged up all the areas where there's corruption.
Yeah,
it's fascinating.
It was a beautiful action.
Too Bad,
the majority of the occupy movement hasn't been able to really put a train of
thought forward that others can grasp.
They have all this media,
all this press.
I tried to,
I don't know if you've seen anything that I've tried to do with them.
I've done,
I've done some talks in La in New York and just really trying to get some seeds
planted as far as what a new social structure may be.
Cause he can complain all day until you put down to some fundamental logical
elements that people can grab,
expand and get into the public consciousness into the Zeitgeists we're doomed
until that happens.
This is going to be one iteration of,
of rogue.
You know,
the idea would be amazing to have uh,
an entire culture filled with cool people and everybody works together.
Like,
boy,
you feel like,
could that work?
Is that possible?
And if it was possible when anybody ever get anything done,
would there be any more competition?
Would they be any more creativity with everybody just be
banging each other and giving each other hugs.
The Fun thing about modern,
a sociological research is that a great number of studies have been done in
those issues.
Yeah.
Incentive is a,
has been a large forest of the market system to assume if we're doing mechanical
stuff yet I'm going to be on a conveyor line which can easily be automated now.
And you know,
be on a subway line.
It just blows my mind.
I'm walking into like a subway restaurant and there's this conveyor belt of
people that you could automate in five seconds if you want to wasting their
lives.
Yeah,
you have to pay people for that.
But when it comes to creativity,
very few are actually motivated by money and money actually inhibits.
There's longer studies that are done by man named Daniel Pink called drive.
I recommend that book to anyone that's interested.
I would think that,
yeah,
if you were just concentrating on money and you would,
that you would lose part of your mental resources that you could have
concentrated on creativity.
So deep in inhibition,
everything I've ever done creatively have never money's a pollutant to me.
You know,
for anything that I've done pollutant,
it hinders my creative response.
Really.
A fucker.
You a hundred percent fucking love money.
I love buying cool shit.
I like going to movies.
I like going to dinner and I don't have to worry how much it costs.
You hate money,
period.
I hate money,
I hate not to do limitless resources.
Yeah.
If I just didn't have,
well,
we're dealing with it.
I hate dealing with bills.
You hate it.
I
hate having money.
I hate getting motherfucker.
I hate having to deal with that part.
I just like waking up doing what I wanted to do.
Creativity like,
like,
like not having to worry about that at all would be amazing
because they'll just go somewhere and give them your pictures and they give you
some meat.
Well,
I mean again,
like of course that you have to get paid he to live,
but if that I could take that whole part out,
that'd be amazing.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's the system that we're,
it's not,
it's absolutely not the best we can do.
You know?
There's,
there's no way this is the best we can do,
especially the stock market.
Man.
I don't give a fuck if you understand it or not.
I watch it.
Sometimes I watch those numbers scroll through the bottom of screen and there's
some fucking dude with his,
his classical attire has traditional attire that he's wearing with his tie and
his his and he's moving around and pointing totally.
These different stocks are going up and down and you know,
it's all based on confidence though.
What kind of a shitbag system have you put together?
What kind of a Goofy fucking number game?
What's all going up and down and shorts and derivatives?
You tell me what the fuck did derivative market is again,
why is it a hundred times bigger than the real market?
What?
Well,
as much as I hate to admit it,
I was a private equity trader for about six years after I left was like,
well,
it was a personal choice to get out of the establishment.
You know,
the only occupation in existence we don't have a boss or a client or reliant on
an audience is in the equity trading.
So were you,
uh,
is it like being an educated guesser?
Is that what it's like?
There's a huge strategy that's called technical analysis that people use.
It's now it's automated behind the scenes by groups like Goldman Sachs that are
raping.
Everybody's slowly but surely.
But no,
there's it from Ted.
I had a lot of respect for the traders independently because of their mindset.
It's a great discipline.
It's like a sport you really have to know you're doing.
You can't just wing it,
it's not gambling.
And then he kind of sense like that.
But as an institution,
those stock market and the whole concept of these representations of equity and
finance and how and how much influence it has in society,
and of course the Dalit driven is blow out and everything else that we've seen,
it's the most cancerous thing on the face of the earth.
It stock market.
It's just unbelievable.
That's why it even exists at all.
I have no clue.
It's the ultimate manifestation of the worst concept of having no social
contribution and invariably making more money than any other sector of the
population.
Even though you create nothing,
you'd do nothing.
And it's just like Wall Street and Michael Douglas.
He's like,
you know,
it's like I create nothing I own.
Yeah,
it's amazing that it's been able to get to the point where it is now.
It's just what a what an out of control ride and you guys,
they may like $40 million a year doing nothing.
Nothing.
And you say to yourself,
well,
here's the market system.
This is the capitalist concept,
right?
Oh everyone.
If you do the most contribution,
you supposed to get the most reward.
That's the underlying tone.
So if you work really hard and didn't really want to and make that invention,
then you can contribute to society.
Now it's you better go.
You're only off of yourself.
Fuck everybody else.
That's what's rewarded in the system across the board and the market system is
just the highest level of that psychological manifestation.
Did it grow
too fast for our little monkey minds?
Is that what it is?
Did Technology and the concept of being able to control money and all the
different things that we have to deal with is variables didn't exist when our
minds are were created.
Our DNA is essentially the same as it was 10,000 years ago.
It's our DNA.
It's really essentially set up for the natural world and then all of a sudden
we've shoved it into this weird new dimension where we're dealing with an
incredible amount of variables.
You're dealing with all kinds of craziness.
I mean,
it's just,
I don't know if the mind is set up to deal with the world that we've created,
which is why it's like a kid at the helm of a car.
It does not drive and he stopped on the fucking gas,
but he's too small to look over the over the dashboard so it is even know where
the fuck he's going.
He's trying to figure this thing out as he goes along.
It's like all of a sudden this little kid has a car,
you know?
And that's what it's like with us.
Like we're like these dumb fucking monkeys and we're,
we're still evolving out of that dumb monkey primal soup and popping out where
we're at.
This monkey that's aware of itself.
And then in the process of becoming aware of itself,
barely getting our shit together,
we've created everything.
We've created nuclear fucking bombs and cell phones and video that you can get a
little screening your pocket and the ability to do things that we would have
never thought possible.
Just 50607080100 years ago.
Sure.
It's almost like no one could have managed this.
It's almost like it blew up sure.
Faster than our reasoning.
Evolution is always natural one way or another.
Whether we destroy ourselves well then I guess the human species was
evolutionary culdesac it's one way or another.
Everything is always right.
You know what I mean?
There's no wrongs here,
but you know the,
the disorder that's in place in society is what concerns me,
which is what you alluded to at the beginning.
You have this huge disorder based on the system that's basically a self
destructive system.
It's not respected.
Any general variables of resource management,
it's not respecting,
you know,
I saw a recent status at,
Oh,
China has less uh,
unemployment than America because they're lax EPA,
if you were wherever they have in China,
the lax environmental issues,
like we should be more like China and reduce our environmental things and they
have like huge smog thing and it's just disgusting destroying ourselves.
One town where they say it's like smoking two packs of cigarettes a day,
just living there.
The skies were like dark gray.
So it's,
it's a disorder that we don't even see it and we just keep killing ourselves.
Whether it's
why is that?
Is it because we still recognize ourselves as individuals and we still haven't
realized that we are a part of a giant super organism that is the human race.
So because people are acting as individuals and then they could do so as a
corporation and do so without guilt.
They act as individuals all going towards one goal,
but under the guise that the company's doing it in the best interest of business
and then they're able to get away with a lot of shit that you just can't get
away with in a,
in a one on one basis
instead of thinking of human beings as a whole.
Putting that at the front
of your ethic,
that's like not even a consideration.
It's like what can we get away with?
What's legal?
Yeah.
You know,
and it's not our fault if it's legal,
go back.
I go back to my early life.
I had a normal upbringing,
but I,
I did all sorts of shit out of college that was highly illegal reselling things.
Just it was whatever you can do to make money,
it didn't matter.
And everyone did too.
It was whatever you needed to do to get money.
And what's happened now with the value system disorder is that since that's the
pursuit,
that's the divine drive of the system.
That's what status is defined by its what your success is defined by that.
Everyone can blindly look the other way with how much destruction is occurring
in the world.
They can look the other way with the wars and the cancers and,
and the just every natural phenomenon that we've come to to disintegrate the,
all the trash that's surrounding the planet right now.
And
like in the war too,
the way people react,
if you know that someone in their family has been molesting someone,
it's almost like they don't want to know the Lord looking away.
They don't want to think about it.
They don't want to do it that way.
If there was right next door,
we'd be thinking about it every fucking day.
The fact that people can just commonly accept the fact that there's no for,
for no reason whatsoever that you could ever argue we're,
we have thousands of dudes with guns in some other part of the world and it
seems normal,
doesn't it?
And it seems normal because it's a part of life and people are born into this
normality.
They don't know any better.
So exactly.
So it is what it is because we feel like the system must be smarter than us.
I mean it's,
it's big,
it's huge,
it's gigantic,
you know,
but it's a,
but it's a group of Goddamn individuals with their own personal interest at hand
and their personal interests will extend to killing people and profiting off of
it if they can get away with it.
My favorite example of that concept was remember the movie network,
which I have little skit mad as hell number when they got frustrated the very
end because they were losing money with the character and they sit around and
they go,
well we could kill him.
And he you think is the audience member that they're just joking.
You think someone that runs on the go,
yeah,
whatever,
but then they're like,
well,
if we do it,
we have to be very careful.
Then the film ends right there.
So you think about that logic,
a human life becomes quite secondary to the most,
the motivations,
especially the higher you go up in this sort of corporate neuroses.
Well,
you know,
it's why I've argued before with people about,
this,
this September 11th especially that the,
I mean I've heard more conversations about,
you know,
what people think happened September 11th and I believe this and I believe that.
And from,
from the very moment I've said,
you don't believe that they'd be willing.
I'm not saying that people did orchestrate any sort of attacks on America.
I'm not saying they let,
I'm not saying anything,
but what I am saying is that we know that they went to war and they said that
there was weapons of mass destruction when there weren't.
So they're willing to kill some people that they don't know.
They know.
They know that the very least they're willing to kill some people that they
don't know in order to push their own agenda.
We know that
just like when they opened Wall Street,
the toxic air and the thousands that have gotten sick since then,
my take on it is they don't know you either,
so you
don't think they would kill you.
Right.
You really think that the p anybody that would orchestrate death for profit,
you don't think they would kill you.
You really think that they would because you're a US citizen.
Just the nature of the,
of the team,
the entire and the entire military,
industrial establishment.
I mean this is a killing machines.
Yeah,
wink.
They wouldn't use that in domestic purposes and not to mention there's so many
examples of that,
their history that people would blindly look at where the quorum,
it's just so sad.
That's why it's offensive when someone says that you're unpatriotic when you see
that and when you see that and you point that out,
no,
you gotta know that is patriotic.
That is very patriotic because that's not what we're supposed to be about.
That's not what this country was supposed to be founded for this,
this country was supposed to be the best alternative.
This country was supposed to be the people that got it together.
Say,
listen,
we have to fucking rules,
man.
Here's the rule.
We separate this from that.
We do this,
we do that.
We don't let anybody do this.
You know,
don't give up your liberties.
You have to have essential liberties.
You have to have guns.
Okay?
You gotta protect yourself from enemies,
foreign and domestic.
You know,
it was all set up.
It was all set up.
Sure.
They knew.
We could argue a little nuances of the founders,
but I understand your point.
That was one thing.
Did you,
did you hear this fucking dummy Newt Gingrich?
This would be king fat headed clown.
This guy actually said that he believed that the founding fathers would be much
more aggressive in the way they would prosecute people for marijuana and that
they would do it probably more violent.
They were growing it themselves.
When they growing it themselves.
It's says in George Washington's fucking diaries that he was separating the mail
from the female plant.
It's very clear that he says he was separating the mail from the female plant
for people don't know when you're growing marijuana,
you've got to separate the mail from the female plant so that the female grows
the buds and that that becomes psychedelic.
That's how you make it.
So you'd get high from it.
Right.
So George Washington is essentially saying he likes to get high,
right.
And he said,
oops,
a little too late.
So he's a fucking stoner.
He separated them too late.
I mean,
what did you have to do back then?
how many different things that you have going on with George Washington was a
fucking stoner dude?
Almost a hundred percent God bless for sure.
They grew it.
And by the way,
they grew hemp and they,
they,
you know,
they grew hamping cause they used it for a lot of things outside of the
psychoactive effects.
They used it for all sorts of different things.
And there's all these different,
this is all z d different passages.
People smoking on their hemp pipe.
It's written in so many different people's diaries and George Washington said
that he did mean his slaves were separating it forum.
Right.
Probably.
But it definitely did.
George have slavery.
You must've had of course.
Right?
They all did.
Yeah.
Right.
So hot right then.
It was,
yeah,
it's a different time,
Brian.
It's a different time.
He was a good man.
Um,
but the,
the point is,
man,
that these,
these fucking people that are in the positions of,
you know,
wanting to be at the helm of this monster,
it's like,
man,
what a shitbag group of people we have to choose from getting,
what do you expect?
You know,
I was go back to one of my great heroes,
George Carlin,
and he's like,
garbage in,
garbage out.
Yeah.
What do you expect from this system now you can argue where these people came
from,
which is where the scam comes in of,
of the entire election.
I mean,
where do
these people come from?
Seriously?
You look at,
he's like,
I don't know.
I don't remember that guy that did.
I don't remember
one Iowa.
They found out that he won.
He beat Mitt Romney,
the crazy religious dude Santorum.
I was.
Right,
right,
right.
Oh,
he's alone.
He's a fucking,
he's a,
uh,
he's a good one.
He's full helm.
Jesus.
He's,
he's Jesus.
Like Leonardo Dicaprio in titanic.
He's at the front of the Jesus ship with his arms up in the air.
This guy's a,
yeah,
no abortion.
No nothing.
Sue Super Jesus.
He's pushing it hard,
but an amazing group of humans we have trying to be at the helm.
Michele Bachmann and a gay husband to this.
If it's really good.
It's a Goddamn Coen brothers movie.
We're living in a Coen brothers movie and a real good one.
No satirical one at that.
Yeah.
It's a big football game and it's sad to me to see how you can't watch the news
at that than covering this as though it's relevant or important to anything.
There's no any decision processes that these people will have the power to take
hold of will actually accomplish anything when it's obvious from our last great
hope Obama,
that big business isn't going anywhere.
Yeah,
I,
it doesn't matter who's in Pa,
even Ron Paul,
if he was magically to be swept in with bulletproof vest on and everything else,
you'll see some dramatic shifts in his policy the moment he comes in because he
knows,
he knows what's actually possible in that environment before the shitstorm hits
them from all sides,
all the examples of what they did to Ralph Nader.
You know with the prostitution thing on it.
Remember that the car company,
there was a basically a car company set up Ralph Nader and in a hotel room with
a prostitute and then documented it cause he was doing all this publicity
against this car company.
How unsafe they're there.
They're cutting costs on their car production.
He found out very discreetly how bad it was.
People were dying and they'd try to set them up and to make them look bad with
this prostitute was incredible.
That's just the tip of the iceberg of all sorts of games that are played.
You can go straight down the whole political spectrum and looked at all the
things that seem random,
the wind ski and all these things.
There's a,
there's a subtle orchestration happening to that.
Not to be conspiratorially oriented,
but that's just the way it is.
You don't mess around.
It's a mafia system.
I want to know where to get casting for that cause I would love to be a part of
the next one.
You know,
like I'm found in Obama's locker room
and I can't walk and
well they must hire it through craigslist.
I mean at this point in time they can easily pay someone to just fuck up your
life.
You know,
pay someone like this is your job be $250,000 your job is to seduce that guy and
go and get it into his life.
Somehow or another.
They're called PR agencies.
Is that what they do?
Well
can go both sides.
They can be positive towards you or they can be hired to be completely black
lifts.
Do gonna make you look like shit.
I know that from my own experience of the weird things that have happened to me,
which I wonder where the roots of some of these things are.
There's people that blog and anti psychiatry,
Peter Joseph matters every single day and follow everything I did like how do
they possibly have time do that
and it makes me think they're being paid to do it.
Maybe I just know of some companies that were listed to me that do the exact
same thing to other people and you don't see them on the forefront.
There are these PR firms that you can use to,
you've probably seen the ones that you can go and use to get bad things removed
from your name on the Internet.
I've heard that on the radio or something like that.
So there's,
there's ones that worked the other direction.
The more of a black op kind of way.
Yeah,
and they're paid to do so.
Wow.
That's really an important stars right now.
Really go after porn stars.
There was a,
this one person broke into a word.
They get tested once a month.
I think I might've talked about this before in broken and still all the records
from all the porn stars and then put them online and then that shit got taken
down eventually and it found out it was just this male porn started.
I did it and then now there's like groups of people that use all those things
that were put online and attack every single porn start online by putting their
information everywhere.
Oh fuck is with people.
Why would they want to do that?
I don't know.
A few different motivations there.
No,
just so it's a weird thing man to we're thing that you know,
people want to hurt other people that badly self appointed guardians of the
status quo that could be labeled a lot.
I picked up a man named jock fresco.
These people that they have,
they're not,
the only thing they have is their identity preservation.
They will fight tooth and nail to make sure whatever they believe is held true.
Whether it's political or religious.
I mean I could,
I can't count how many death threats I got since the first film came out.
Well,
you're quite just questioning the status quo.
All they're doing is fucking on camera.
Why would somebody want to jet harm?
Well,
because if,
say some deeply religious individuals sees a porno or catches this sun with it
or something like that,
they feel a huge threat there for whatever purpose.
You'd be surprised what motivations people,
that's the root cause.
The root,
the root issue is how fucking dumb people are and what a giant percentage of
them are just so off the tracks and in the woods,
misinformed a condition.
How do you turn those folks around?
Cause I think you can't really have this next level society until you get those
folks to uh,
on track.
Look if that's one of the things about living in a nice neighborhood.
If you live in a nice neighborhood,
you know,
there's generally a lot less financial strife.
So people are a little bit more calm.
You know,
it's one of the things that people don't like about living in neighborhoods
where people are poor.
You know,
there's a lot of tension and sometimes shit goes down.
Sure.
Well,
you got to get everybody to the level of no tension,
you know,
in order to have a,
a beautiful society.
How the hell do you do that?
As you pointed out earlier,
you start with the kids,
you make,
uh,
there's,
there's a deeply religious,
uh,
anti structure thing going on in the world where everyone thinks they can just
keep having kids.
And it doesn't matter what the resources of the planet,
you know,
it's,
it doesn't matter that no.
Dot.
Don't you dare tell them how to raise their kids,
forget any kind of instruction.
You know,
that he kids,
people have natural pre-programming.
It's pretty obvious what the men did.
You Watch that guy's moving forward a whole,
and that's the very beginning.
I was like us moving forward on the development of kids now it little small
nuances can mess them up for the rest of their lives.
Whether it's goes to drug addiction,
whether it goes to mental disorders or even physical disorders and no attention
has been put on there.
If there's anything that I would like to see put in the public educational
fountain,
it would be how to really think about your kids,
how important it is,
how the earliest things that happened to them all fucked them up the rest of
their lives.
If they're not carefully,
carefully collard or carefully orchestrated Lawan vulnerability.
We're not talking about like holding kids down and making them do things in a
structured way.
It's allowing the vulnerability of this natural organism to come to fruition.
A Horse,
for example,
falls right out of the horse that Boren faltered.
They can walk boom,
humans because of evolution,
they come out way too early.
So the susceptibility of the,
of the,
the infant is so massive and so misunderstood.
Up until now that people have done things to their kids that have really fucked
them up for their whole lives at the infancy stage because of how much
developmental requirements are actually,
they're,
the protections are gone.
So it's a huge topic and there's a lot of people I could list,
uh,
that can,
that can describe those issues in tax.
The got him gathered.
Mateo has a really good one.
So what is the best case scenario?
It was the best case scenario that the [inaudible] movement takes place after
some sort of a collapse and we develop a new society that's based on using of
natural resources universally and across the board,
and there's no hierarchy of citizenship and,
and then the people are on the outside.
What do we do?
We fight them off.
Well,
you would want to hope it's hard to put join.
You'd want to hope that whatever the cataclysmic may manifest itself to be,
that's pending,
that those on the sidelines,
that barbarians at the gate as they might have been,
would eventually turn it around to see the folly of their ways as well.
You know,
it's hard to predict.
It's like I smooth.
It was really a movement of logic and reason.
It's like,
okay,
here's,
we have,
we have technological automation.
You know what?
People are being replaced by automation.
In fact,
the great driver of unemployment now is automation.
They won't admit it.
Most economists will not,
a few are coming out now in the medium that you can go back to the Roosevelt
administration.
They actually wanted to have a stop on technological invention during the
industrial revolution because of how fast people were being replaced by
machines.
And that is the core driver of all unemployment you see in the world today
period.
So what does that mean?
What is the logic say?
Well we can produce more with less.
We don't need people to slave over some shitty factory job anymore.
We automated no vacations,
higher,
much higher degree of accuracy.
Machines can do things.
There's all sorts of a modular machines now that can do things like scientific
research,
extremely specific things,
thinking machines,
people like Ray Kurzweil and all this massive evolution I could ramble on for a
long time.
What does that mean for Human Labor?
Do we keep human labor as a requirement to live your right to life is to get
income or do you create a new system that says,
okay,
let's go full forward with machine automation,
all sectors possible and fill in the gaps with whomever is willing to do so.
And I think the abundance produced when enable US society to exist without
people needing money every minute of the day.
What happens
to all those people that were working on those assembly jobs?
Well,
they at this stage they wouldn't know what the fuck to do,
right?
But if you evolve it out,
if you really think about this for long periods of time,
you get the problem we're going to have to face eventually.
Well face it now tell until later,
until you see someone in power say,
okay,
we're going to start to automate and basically do a form of socialization if you
will,
giving people free food free energy in order to supplement them for their law,
their lack of purchasing power,
which is what's happening and tell someone starts to do that in government or
having the workday.
Like,
if Obama was smart and good Bunch of Roosevelt administration,
they would have put in uh,
a mandate or whatever you'd want to call it,
where the corporations received some type of subsidy where they would have the
work day and they would hire twice the amount of people for that corporation,
giving them the sustenance income.
The that would be,
that would be applicable would be probably a little bit reduced.
But what else do you do?
They're not going to do that because the core motivations,
so against it,
corporations responsibilities to the shareholders.
Shareholders don't want to see anything like that.
What happens when someone lays a whole bunch of employees and stock market and
the stock goes up?
Remember it's just sick.
The whole things backwards.
So back to my point and tell automation,
uh,
no one's going to stop automation cause it's a profit driven thing.
It costs less money to automate than it does to use people.
And that's what you call the contradiction of capitalism.
And the words of Karl Marx,
believe it or not,
he recognizes this logo and all you have is this thing collaging together.
That is unreconcilable.
And tell a new social system system is put in place,
what do you think is going to happen with the current system?
How much time do you think we have before?
It's just chaos in the streets and I mean,
it's already chaos and most of the world in pockets,
I think,
I think 2012 was in,
it'd be prophecy side,
I think 2012 and be a very interesting year.
It's amazing that things have accelerated this far,
this close to 2012 when you look at it from a,
the standpoint,
sure,
everybody thinks well,
it's like the boy who cried wolf.
It's like at a certain point in time like y two K and this and that and you know
the fucking Pleiades and where's Nibiru?
And at a certain point in time like,
ah,
right,
well you're fucking apocalypse talk,
stop it.
But then as you get closer and closer to 2012 you're like,
man,
you know,
maybe the Mayans were on assumption.
Well,
I doubt that.
But uh,
what,
what does scare me is the self feeling shit.
And then people are gonna be jumping out of windows and shooting things up and
all the ones that have convinced themselves if some diluted idea,
that's going to be very interesting.
Well,
the other,
oh,
the other thing is like no one is saying it's going to be the end of the world.
It's just the end of this calendar could be a new era.
That's awesome.
You know,
it very easily could it,
my personal analysis,
the end of the Mayan calendar is the end of the age of Pisces.
That's it.
That's the great year.
Starts again with the age of Aquarius is too hard to predict.
You have like a 1500 to 3000 year buffer.
It's 2020 6,000 year cycle in the procession of the equinoxes.
And that's what I think it is.
Um,
but whatever,
I don't pay attention to those things,
but as far as,
I don't pay attention to it,
but I do pay attention to the fact that so many people pay attention to it.
Well,
of course,
you know,
I'm fascinated by astrology.
I don't know if I,
I'm,
I'm a believer in it 100% but I think it's amazing that they can,
you know,
halfway nailed down personalities and different traits when they're really good
at it.
And we could argue on that one.
The power of suggestion is a,
is quite phenomenal in the world today.
You'd be amazed.
And then as far as like structuring questions as far as structuring,
leading people into,
yeah,
I've seen that.
I've seen like psychic stuff,
people do shit like that,
but I'm not even talking about that.
I'm talking about like somebody giving you a date and some of those real
astrologists they want to know like what time you were born.
And I don't know if it's real,
but it's amazing that it's been around so long it,
I do not know if it's real,
but it's amazing that at one point in time someone actually dedicated enough
time to writing down some sort of a system to figure out which different things
that are in line when you're born in the [inaudible].
It's kind of amazing really.
I think it's beautiful.
Beautiful from the standpoint,
a cultural standpoint to find your place in the universe.
Think other people are doing,
they're looking at the sky,
it looks flat and two d they think about associations.
They want to feel like they're connected to it.
The whole definition of God,
and if you go back to my first film,
most natural phenomenon,
stellar cults originated,
merged into the Islam.
Judeo Christian Islamic religion by symbolism just became his historize
basically.
But you know,
the beauty of it is that people are trying to relate to something.
That's what I see.
But they still thought the sky was flat,
right?
So the constellations don't even exist.
They don't actually know actually there.
They just looked that way.
You know,
they thought,
who was,
they thought this guy was flat.
Well,
if you look at the sky,
it looks perfectly flat and the constellations and the depictions are actually
flat.
That's how they're important.
That's why they have a little animal things and things like that.
And the Sun rising.
Let's say there's summer solstice,
I believe that's the birth note or most the spring equinox,
you can't remember.
It's a completely to Di Prima Fascia is surface flatland view and it doesn't
hold any actual validity because they had no idea that it was actually the
depth.
You know the depth of the stars and their,
their radiants is so far away,
they're burning out there changing.
There's morphine,
there's expansion.
So you know,
so they just looked at it as like almost like a picture of flat two dimensional
picture stance is going to fall down.
It's amazing that they did that for so long though.
They really studied the constellations.
I guess that's a beautiful art form.
It's a beautiful concept
that's outside.
Where's that outside?
Who?
Who,
who's the mother beating?
Nice kid.
Her Kid.
Lovely Pasadena culture.
Well this is the only thing that's the worst you have to worry about Pasadena.
You know,
this is not like,
you know what's funny is jungles of Africa.
I know this girl that I was a stripper a long time ago and she found out about
you from the green room of a strip club.
There was a hairdryer hair designer that was,
he was a gay guy that was in love with your shit.
And so he used to tag you throughout San Francisco and in this green room of a
strip club,
your,
your tag is all over.
He just tagged the fuck out of this green room.
That's how she found out about it.
And then she got so moved by your movie that she started posting flyers around
San Francisco,
uh,
to promote your movie because she was so moved by her.
That
was what it was so phenomenal on the,
uh,
the original owner.
It still persists to this day on its own.
I did know publicity for any of these things.
It's always been self driven.
It somehow,
it seemed to tap into some element of people that they appreciate it and felt
the need to re communicate to other people,
which is inadvertent to me.
I certainly didn't anticipate that,
but yeah,
it was,
it blown your mind.
Well,
I get these,
I get these marketing calls occasionally or emails from these marketing jackass
is like,
how did you do that?
What kind of,
what kind of algorithms are you using in your viral media?
Like it's just word of mouth,
man.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Highly envy.
The film series is a highly envied by a lot of people.
They're trying to,
there's a lot of films trying to duplicate the idea to duplicate the concept and
build kind of a farce community out of it.
And the same way that was natural to the movement.
So,
but anyway,
what do you expect?
It's amazing.
Everyone assumes dollar signs and there's a lot of people around.
Yeah,
of course.
Well there's um,
there's always been someone at the helm of something at different points in
time,
you know,
different cultures,
different religions,
different,
you know,
different kingdoms has always been someone with a new idea.
And I think everybody's sort of recognizes that this thing is falling apart.
No one's buying anymore.
And a new things going to come along,
man.
And we've got to jump on it.
We're going to jump on it because this is,
this really is the future because this,
this dying animal that you see this,
this fucking elephant and donkey system is stupid.
It's stupid.
And everybody recognizes it's destroying us.
Just look around.
It's destroying the fabric of almost everything that you see around you.
You have every life support systems in decline.
Our psychology is really fucked up.
And if he's taken a look around what coach was doing today,
I mean the public health issue is bad enough.
I'm just waiting for the tipping point where,
where uh,
the lifespan starts to tip cause I think it's just a matter of time.
I have a friend that has a 10 year old and she has her 10 year is in school and
uh,
you know,
he's an active kid and the psychologist or psychiatrist,
I guess it would be for school,
is trying to give the kid trucks and he says,
well he's a good kid.
He's not,
he's not a,
he just gets bored in class and he acts up a little bit but he doesn't need to
be drugged.
And she goes,
you're so easy.
You're so quick to drug them.
Like how many kids in his classes are,
are,
are on drugs.
And he says,
well I am not an liberty to give that it's confidential information,
but let me tell you it's somewhere near half.
So I don't know why the fuck he would say that.
He's not at liberty.
So,
and then she goes,
wait a minute,
a half,
half.
Do you know you think half of the kids in school have a mental problem to the
point where they need drugs?
Wow,
that's amazing.
That is amazing that there's someone out there that is a professional that's
able to do something like that.
Now this is a woman telling me about her child.
I do not know for numbers were correct.
You know,
I mean she,
she might've just,
I don't see she's adding marijuana on a dummy though.
She's not a dummy,
you know?
And she was,
she was telling me this and it made a whole lot of sense to me and I was like,
that is amazing that they're just,
they're so willing to drug people and that's a of sickness.
Absolutely.
I mean,
it's fucking sucks.
Okay.
There's a reason why you kids moving around.
He's healthy.
He's healthy as brainworks great creative.
Yeah.
He's,
and he's getting all this input that blows and he knows he can get out of that
class and play video games and have laughs with his friends and,
and say hi to girls.
And that would be awesome,
but right now this sucks and it just,
I can't take the suck any longer.
It's like,
it's like you're telling me that the only way to learn is to be board into a
fucking coma and just accept this really low frequency of memorizing shit that
some other asshole figured out and so that's,
that's,
that's it.
That's what school is every day.
Just pounding it into you that the only way to get through this is you're going
to have to hate it when meanwhile everything else you get good at every game you
get good at,
you get good at because you love it.
You know,
and get good at video games because they're fun.
When you get to be a bad asset,
a video game,
it's because that video games.
Awesome.
Why do you guys get good at basketball?
Because it's fun to be good at basketball.
When you hit that three pointer,
it's fucking fun.
Everything else that you get good at,
it's fun except the shit that you have to deal with in school.
Unmotivated people,
they're underpaid and you want to talk about like the symptom of a sick society.
The fact that we put so little emphasis on schools,
so little emphasis on teaching.
It should be an honor
fields from the plant to let guard over people's children.
Man,
you should be the most honorable,
respectable people available.
Super Intelligent and super well paid.
We should be paying teachers fuckloads of money,
man.
You know,
they should be,
it should be like a prestigious position.
It should be something that you like really aspire to instead of something where
it's a passion,
but you're getting fucked by the system.
We,
you barely have enough money to eat.
You know,
you look at how much a teacher makes in a public school system,
it's it fucking deplorable.
It's amazing that it's accepted.
It's like for whatever reason,
we don't step out of boundaries and,
and look at it objectively and go,
we've got some core problems and a big part of it is our children and they
developed to become shitty fucking human beings against their own intentions.
It's not like they want to suck out.
The kids don't want to suck his,
his are just balls of potential
victims.
The victims of a system that really doesn't care.
It doesn't understand,
doesn't put any resources towards it.
It's like you have so much money to go to war and you have so little to go to
school.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
It's amazing that you've worked out the numbers that way.
What level of a imposition you can have is to go to college,
get $80,000 worth of debt and then guess what?
You ripe to be enslaved and some hideous corporate estate
you just hoping you can afford a Lexus next year.
You know,
every day just live in a slave.
But back to the drug issue just preps kids now so they can,
when they get to be adults and try to figure out why they're so miserable,
why they hate their job,
while they have no contribution to society,
why they don't have any artistic energy anymore.
Well that's perfect cause then you can give them the PROZAC and give them all
the other drugs that will nullify them to make them adhere to this process.
Yeah.
Poor little guys.
So if you analyze all that and use statistical view,
public health from a psychological and mental health standpoint,
you look at depression rates,
you look at everything.
Then you look at the environmental problems you look at,
you just go straight down the spectrum of public health to physical health too,
to environmental health.
You have one massive drop off.
It's ridiculous,
and that's,
that's the data idea with far too often,
and that's why I think the system can hold up for that much longer.
I mean,
the cancer rates are out of control for one.
As a general rule,
there's more cancer occurring now than ever before.
There's too many of us.
Well,
no,
it's not too many of us know.
Nope.
I don't agree with that at all.
That's,
that's some people intuitively speaking,
you'd want to say that.
I think the board can hold many,
many more times the number of people if it was properly structured,
but we have to also deal with something different as far as like fuel,
right?
We can't be,
we can't be a carbon
fossil fuel base.
Not Great.
Paradigm shift is we've been living off of fossil deposits,
which is one of those ignorant things possible.
Since we're surrounded by the movement of energy from the Sun,
new everything else,
we have these,
uh,
we've,
there's no crisis in the energy.
There's no energy problem.
There's only the crisis of ignorance as I stated before.
And that's really the big thing.
We have plenty of energy.
So you think,
um,
uh,
ideally,
especially in southern California,
we should have like solar domes,
right?
It should be like,
should be solar.
They're there.
Well you should.
Well,
if you really want to hear it too,
it,
you should hovering in the sky,
all solar,
you just go with it.
You go local,
you take this block which has plenty of sun exposure and you apply for the forte
paints and high,
high quality advancements and does not,
it does very little money going into the research.
By the way.
It's hard to get any kind of funding for those things.
So if you imagine how fast we could advance with these renewable mediums
localized,
if we actually put the energy into them,
you can do the extrapolation on how far we'd become cause technology just
continues to move beyond our expectations.
Don't you need batteries though?
For Solar?
Between super capacitors and and hydrogen,
which is the new idea.
You could store it at these things for easily overcome the intermittency of
solar easily through battery technology.
The problem with battery technology,
again,
in the market system,
you want constant turnover.
You want scarcity,
you want people to go back and buy more batteries because that's what this
entire system and also the problem minerals to create the batteries like lithium
ion and they get to go for hydrogen.
But uh,
now I think hydrogen batteries or hydrogen storage storage.
So this would not be a solar issue then because you can't,
usually you bring the solar into it,
you bring solar power and then you convert that into hydrogen.
Somehow it's stored.
It's stored in the water,
stored in the hydrogen.
How's that?
That's a new technology that's been internal.
So no need for batteries,
no needs for better my on nothing,
no need for the minerals that they get in the car.
You might have to have some lithium ion in intermittent sense dependent on how
the battery is constructed or but super capacitors,
which is another concept which isn't utilized.
You know how you like your computer as capacitors,
that store energy,
a very different technology
than the standard battery,
which is kind of like a,
you fill it in there.
There's many different forms and there's a great deal of advancement there and
there's really nothing that I can find that would inhibit storage for an
admitted NSI from solar.
If you really put your mind to it.
There's to say that would take some more deep analysis,
but I can't imagine we'd run out of minerals just for that.
Well,
it's just,
it's always been ironic to me that the,
the,
the chain from minerals coming out of the ground to the super advanced
technology,
just such a barbaric chain,
and they look down at the people in no shoes with pick axes,
pulling the minerals out of the ground,
the Congo and how that eventually gets to your apple laptop.
I was like,
wow.
It's pretty fascinating that,
that that is all,
I mean that that's a part of the equation.
The part of the equation for high technology,
whether it's solar power,
anything is you need the minerals from Africa of course,
and that's how they're extracting those fucking things
and tell him.
Molecular engineering comes into play and we've begin to synthesize these,
these raw materials from scratch through molecular engineering,
which is around the corner probably within the next 50 60 years.
It's already small advancements in that.
See,
the more you just liked,
that's alchemy.
It is kind of kind of,
yeah,
sure.
That's what people had predicted.
Well,
you remember probably the old many years ago,
it was one of the companies,
they spelled their name and little Adams and they showed it in the magnifying
glass at big feet.
We've come a long way since then and there's a lot of great futurist ideas out
there that can basically create replicators for your home where you're not going
to be like me going to a store to buy anything.
You're going to be creating these things in your home.
And if there's anything that will destroy the market system quite rapidly,
it will be advancements like that.
How do you possibly maintain labor systems where you can synthesize a laptop in
one swoop,
download the model from your computer,
it goes into this vat,
it's in this,
this dust,
and then the Milan molecular element is released just like you print into a
printer or three d printing,
which I had in my feel moving forward as a primitive notion of that they can
print for cars now in one swoop.
There's so much advanced technology out there that is not known that would solve
so many problems.
Uh,
it's frustrating.
It's very frustrating.
And the very fact that these efficiencies are there and not being pushed as fast
as they should be,
as even more frustrating.
But you see why?
Why?
Because efficiency is the enemy of everything that turns a profit that we want.
We want to serve this everything.
We don't want to solve problems.
We want people with cancer not to cure the cancer we want.
That's an ethic though that they think about that.
No,
it's subconscious.
It's syntax of thought.
They don't necessarily think that way.
Just like guys sitting around a room and the Pentagon start to justify killing
3000 people.
They're not thinking in terms of being murderers or anything else.
They're thinking in terms of business.
So you know,
if you,
if you want to make a laptop and you want people to buy it again,
that things die probably three years from the time you buy it in different
component problems that will go on.
It doesn't mean it has to know,
but the turnover is so important.
Efficient efficiency is the driver of this system,
which is why we had the pollution problems,
the waste problems and the health problems.
And why did they feed in together and while you are whole GDP is literally
driven by sickness and inefficiency and waste.
That's the,
if there's anything that blows my mind,
it's how anti economic,
our current system really is on all levels.
So if you want to solve problems,
you want to make a car that lasts 60 years,
that's easily interchangeable.
That can be,
excuse me,
more than that.
Bailey a hundred years,
easily interchangeable.
They can be updated.
You want to make a smart phone that has the longest lasting components.
They don't need to throw away.
These things could be done if we wanted to do it,
but the be the be an enema to what the market system requires for constant
turnover,
constant turnover,
constant money.
Circulation means more jobs.
So it's planned obsolescence you think?
Is this like a business model?
It's planned and intrinsic.
Another level level is in transactions that people,
you know,
they build things the best they can and they don't last.
They just break two levels to it.
Planned obsolescence is very real.
You can go into historical archives of car companies to know that they
strategize.
I can guarantee you the people behind apple sit there and their rooms and they
had full on statistics kind of operating systems.
Oh you have an operating system update the software,
the software scan is even worse cause that's just numb ones and Zeros.
The fact that they even charge over and over for that more hilarious.
That's planned obsolescence.
Intrinsic obsolescence is even more fucked up if you think about it.
That computer for it to be built has to go through the engine of the industrial
profit complex,
which means all the components,
the extraction,
everything else someone's taking off the top throughout the entire thing.
Right.
And there's cost efficiency at the very end.
So if you're apple computer,
you bought a by the components to make your computer.
You can't buy necessarily the highest grade level stuff in order to remain
competitive against the other people that are selling computers similar like
windows or whatever.
So you have to constantly be a little bit behind in order to be competitive so
you can drop the price.
But there was,
the quality of the product has to be diminished immediately for people to afford
it.
The equation of,
of cost efficiency refuses to allow the best possible goods to be produced at
any one time period.
It's a rule.
It's a natural evolution,
natural and natural dynamic,
if you will,
of what it means to save money and to make profit.
So everything's a piece of shit the moment it's produced.
Yeah.
Well that's separate.
The shit like Ferrari's.
Even a Ferrari though.
Think about the price of a Ferrari though.
That's why it's so expensive part.
I mean they really make the best shit they can,
but it's not really the best.
Oh fuck yeah,
it is four or five,
eight Italia.
Have you seen that thing?
Twin clutch gearbox,
ridiculously powered VA mid engine.
Supercar come on man.
That's about as good as human beings have ever created.
It really is.
It's,
it's the,
the peak of engineering,
the there,
you know,
they use race car driving to,
to,
to engineer their cars.
They push cars to the limit and every year they go around the Newburg ring like
a couple of seconds faster and everybody's like straining for like the new
Porsche is a seven minutes and 40 seconds.
The new nine 11 and that's like this is an electric,
no,
it's not electric,
but they have,
they have cars that they
have developed that are electric.
Porsche has a,
they had a um,
a gt three cup car that they raced in the 24 hour race that was a,
that was an electric car.
They're definitely trying to come up with electrical technology,
but they're are making the best cars they can make.
Well,
let's define,
get to like there's certain things that are being done right now.
They're at the peak of production.
Even though they are being produced,
they're essentially making like some high end shit that's the best they can
make.
We could probably argue that one because if you look at all the advanced
propulsion technology that's used in NASA,
why aren't they applying such things like that?
You can try to thought not exactly,
but there are all sorts of things that could be that are probably more advanced
than either of us,
either of us know that could be applied to that Ferrari but they're not because
I actually sense of therefore no one will be able to anyway
gas that you could get a pump either you have to work within no skin strains
cause our gas is actually really low compared to a,
like our octane's late [inaudible] 91 in other parts of the country.
I know you can get like 93 or four.
Sure.
So I guess it's bad to have more octane.
But you see my point though,
you can't make something really that people can buy it.
But I see what you're saying.
Demograph heart.
It's demographic targeted too.
So what's the majority,
what are the majority of people?
Majority of people are lower and middle class.
You make shit that doesn't work very well so they can afford it and invariably
it breaks and they suffer in the end because they have to deal with the constant
cyclical turnover and the need to constantly repair and everything else.
When everything hits the fan and you start your calls,
what,
what will everyone do for a job?
How does everyone get?
You'll be doing my laundry.
I'll be doing your laundry.
I'm not good at laundry done and you're not going to want me to do your laundry,
right?
Um,
what did she do?
What does everybody get a job?
I mean,
what does it become?
Communism.
I mean,
how do you figure out what the fuck everybody does to contribute to this thing?
What if you,
you know what if you're a lazy cunt,
how do we deal with Lacey,
consonant
number,
that lazy concert victims of culture,
right?
And you know,
that's,
that's the threshold here is where do we take them on mushroom trips and
straighten them out who we do?
Well,
think about it this way.
If you had a kid go into a store and they,
there's a kid in his mother and the kid,
it's today and the kid goes and grabs some stuff and shoves it in his pockets.
The mom says,
no,
that's stealing slaps the kid's hand.
The kid learns a valuable lesson in his values are altered,
right?
Think about the same type of idea where we go into a store,
there's no money.
It's not even a store.
It's a,
it's a supply house.
And a kid goes in and grabs whole handfuls of shit that is completely
unnecessary because there's no utility for it.
And the mother says,
no,
that's not what we do because we don't need all of that.
It has to be there and we'll come back and get it later as we need it because
the systems that efficient.
So you see how the value programming is very easy to adapt.
So throughout time you'd begin to change people's values,
how they relate to their environment.
Imagine if you didn't have to worry about money,
Joe,
imagine the extent that you could pursue in your life the interest that you
found interesting.
And invariably I guarantee you,
if you look
at how people respond,
especially in their later years when they get more introspective,
everyone wants to feel like they're contributing to society.
Everyone wants to feel like they've done something social,
so that kind of greed,
self absorbed share,
that's a very adolescent immature thing and it's probably there to a certain
effect and the evolution of the adaptation of the human being as he grows.
But if you have a system doesn't support or reinforce those issues,
the then the miserable cock suckers and dimwits and assholes and jerk off small
won't materialize.
They need,
but they're here.
We need to figure out how to get rid of them either to get rid of him or to fix
them and bring them up.
That's going to be very difficult because that's a real issue.
It's a real,
it's super real issue at the core of everything.
It's an educational problems.
Why Doug?
Stan Hope,
how to stop doing as parties in the desert.
It is what it is.
I didn't hear Doug,
Doug,
Stan hope,
my buddy and a hilarious comedian used to have these parties in the desert.
But you would have like,
you know,
anybody could come and everybody knew about it online.
So you would have like a thousand really cool people and to just unbearable
Douche.
Sure.
And the too unbearable douchebags would make the,
make the whole party useless.
And those guys need to be,
you have new,
you have to figure out what to do with them.
They,
there's some people out there that are off fucking mess,
not an issue of having this beautiful solar dome.
Where y'all all this hippie pussy inside.
Just line it up for you.
We're still going to have to deal with the barbarians at the gates cause
otherwise they liked the,
like the New Orleans,
it's stormed Egypt and took over the pyramids.
They're going to come in and rush this bitch.
Well I don't,
I don't see this materializing in some isolated place,
uh,
where the barbarians are waiting on the sidelines to uh,
there,
there are people.
Yeah,
the power went out.
Right now there'd be hordes of our bearings on the street with hockey sticks and
guns and whatever the fuck they could look at whatever the fuck you had.
And that would last for a little while until,
until someone said,
yeah,
you don't have to do that if we just calm down a moment.
So the transition can happen.
Even with the people that we have now that seem to be the creme de la creme,
the victims of this culture,
it just going to take a great deal of care.
And I think as a natural consequences,
the system fails.
There'll be a great number of people that will turn around faster than you would
believe.
Once their needs are pulled away from them,
they realized that their needs have to come from some other process or somewhere
else.
Then the adaptation becomes natural.
Well,
one of the things about the occupy Wall Street movement that's fascinated me is
the idea that all these people sort of lived together.
You know,
they don't,
they're not just,
you know,
protesting together.
They have fucking tents and they have a community there.
They have books you could like go to their little library and read their books.
They have,
I'm all set up there,
you know that's so,
I mean it's essentially right now it's not really a commune but it's on its way
and they could easily,
it's one of those guys said,
listen man,
my car,
my cousin has a hundred acres out in the wilderness and they have fruit trees
and they have the grow vegetables and it's animals and we can hide and we can
make a fucking culture.
Let's do this.
As long as we don't show any aggression towards the government.
Certainly been done before,
but then they shut you down and they go Waco on your ass and fucking toys the
building.
Or if you're a whole nother country,
like the attempts of the Bolshevik revolution of some something new,
despite what anyone ever thought of communism,
that was quickly shut down as a concept by the western powers.
You gotta be totally nonthreatening.
If you want to start this cult,
we have to like get a nice piece of property,
but it's got to be real pretty and there's no property.
This isn't a,
this is an evolution of ideas.
We're not going to,
we're not going to set up any shit on me,
man.
You're going to need a car,
a camp.
Can they get an EAD camp,
Peter?
Right.
Come on man.
Right,
right outside of Arizona and my Jim,
Jim Jones glasses.
You don't need glasses,
dude.
You're going to be fine.
You're really good at this.
You can make it back to these people and just,
and just run the whole big solar dome right there from a Sonoma Sonoma's a good
spot.
They're prepared.
They're accepting it.
They're ready.
They've got the crystals out there ready to take the vitamin.
Yeah.
Led is going to happen,
man.
Do you,
you think that,
um,
we're going to have a situation where money is going to lose all of its value,
where it's going to be so bad and the economy's going to get bankrupts so
inextricably that we're going to be stuck in a situation where we're like,
like Russia was at one point in time or you know,
where they were waiting on line with bales of money to buy a loaf of bread.
Well,
you're already do you see
in the military realization of the police,
you're already seeing the social destabilization spread because of the faulty
economic premise that is creating the unemployment that is creating the debt
crisis that will invariably highly be very inhibited by the energy crisis if
massive moves aren't met.
So the three issues,
as I mentioned before,
is the unemployment crisis.
And I can expand on that.
Let's think about this for a second.
If you have technology replacing human labor,
which is emitted across the board now mostly by colonists as opposed to
economist,
because economists market economists are an extreme denial on this one and many
a debate.
You replace people,
but you're not just replacing their job to replacing their ability to purchase
other stuff and circulate the economy and that that's even worse.
And it,
it's farthest extension.
That means that the entire fuel of growth is being slowly shut down,
which means that the system will lose more and more,
and the system will eventually just stifled to a point that it can't operate
anymore apart from common or medial jobs or problems that might arise.
But there's no way you're going to continue employing people on this planet and
numbers that we have in the past.
It's all downhill from here because the profit motivation to replace people by
machines is inherent to the interest to save money.
Mcdonald's has had systems on the shelf for 20 years now that would replace
everyone in their kitchen.
Now they are the front kiosk systems as well.
They don't do it only because they're corporate view is to be social and as an
employer they have a stake in that.
Even though it's built the contrary to logic and if you look carefully,
they are automating very,
very slowly.
Just like all the grocery stores are automating,
you're reducing purchasing power and there's no way this system's going to
maintain itself.
Once that continues and accelerates,
it's the contradiction of capitalism,
so the idea of human labor is becoming obsolete.
That in its own right is going to inspire some serious reflection and some
massive upheavals.
It's going to be
calling everybody contribute.
Is it possible that everybody can find their own unique way to contribute
outside of manufacturing things outside of working menial jobs outside of fast
food supermarkets,
retail,
when you remember that,
uh,
it's a lot of jobs.
Consumption is twice what it was now than it was in World War II.
Advertising as completely fucking per capita,
twice per person,
per person.
The average person's in America,
since World War Two consumes twice the amount of shit,
which obviously means something's askew.
Why?
Why is that?
Why do we feel the need to have all this other excess stuff?
Socially speaking?
If you go to a small tribes that aren't,
don't have access to television,
they're very,
very happy with it,
very minimalistic life.
They don't,
their happiness isn't contingent upon how they compare themselves to others or
any type of notion of value that they live in,
the culture that's been manifest within the resources around them.
And they happier than any American with the multimillion dollar house and
everything else,
which is usually an antidepressants.
So we have as a neuroses that's been built,
which is fueling all of this industry that's completely irrelevant basically.
And the more that happens,
the more we try to invent new jobs.
You know,
I had one guy,
economist tell me that,
oh,
we're just going to end up using Facebook money.
Say we'll have everybody on the Internet doing something with Facebook or some
other network was somehow they gain credits and they'll use those credits as
currency now.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Something,
I dunno know,
I was talking about this like a year ago.
Remember this,
just remember Joe,
we talked about where the future's going to be post with your buddy.
And my point is it wouldn't surprise me if we reached that point where you have
a whole group of these freaks like straight out like idiocracy or something
where they're all doing the most relevant actions are relevant.
Waste of life,
waste of the human brain does nothing to contribute just to maintain the,
the idea of employment.
So I don't think that's going to happen.
I think it's going to self destruct.
Once the energy crisis hits and the debt crisis,
which continues to strangle hold the entire planet,
these three things will combine.
I can't predict the future,
but I think within a couple of years you're going to see some very,
very radical shifts in a lot of governments on this planet.
I think a lot of detachment will occur.
You're going to see an extension of military invasions.
They got out of a rock,
they're going to go into a raw and they gotta get their energy resources there.
They've got a secure in the Middle East for other resources as far as minerals
and gold and other things that are there too.
There's a,
there's a,
the faster collapses,
the more criminal the meltdown becomes and that's something too I think people
should pay attention to and we haven't even seen shit yet.
Now that we have time holes.
By the way,
Joe,
did you see that Pentagon created some time
and now they can make it Vince disappear?
Well No.
First of all you're dealing with like a nanoseconds you're dealing with right
now.
This is version one
and this is only what they're telling us about they they,
they could have been having these time holes for some time.
I think so because essentially the Pentagon is using guys that are at the
forefront of science and the forefront of science is pretty,
it's published.
It's pretty much out there.
Everybody knows pretty much what everybody is working on.
I mean not,
and they mean there are,
there's some definitely some black op projects,
but uh,
you know,
these guys is that there's not a whole lot of these dudes and the way they stay
at this level of,
you know,
of being a bad superintelligent motherfucker have to exchange information.
How far,
how long is it?
Just a few seconds.
Like some athletic my nipple and I'd be like,
who did this?
No,
you wouldn't even believe
receive it.
There's no way you'd be able to perceive it.
But the idea is that this is just one full 40 pico seconds.
That's what it is.
It's what it's,
the research is admit there's a big difference between human hiding.
Laser means 40 picoseconds and hiding military operations.
Lasting minutes or even several seconds.
But the idea is that they've,
they've started it.
Wow.
Yeah.
They started some interesting,
exciting.
That is really exciting.
You know what,
man,
it's,
it isn't.
It isn't.
I mean everything is military.
It's the Pentagon is the one that fucking came up with this.
That's the most incredible thing.
Like when you look at our capacity for innovation,
they're the really impressive shit is all the stuff that blows things.
The fuck up course.
You know,
look,
cell phone cameras are really impressive.
It's really impressive that you can make a little video and make a movie from
your phone.
You know?
It's way more impressive.
You drop a little box out of a plane and a city evaporates.
That's incredible.
You know?
And what is that?
That's just,
that's,
you know,
that's the peak of our technology,
the peak of our technology and it's the most impressive as a fucking laser beam
to cut the earth and half.
You know,
if there's any,
any better proxy,
I'm not quite sure what is,
you know,
if you look at how much energy and ingenuity is going into these things,
what if we apply that idea to feeding people?
What if we apply that idea to doing actually relevant
the hard nose folks that occasionally I agree with.
Would say,
we know what these fucks.
They don't feed themselves.
This is evolution out there.
They're supposed to be figuring it out.
It was supposed to be getting it together,
which I don't.
I don't a hundred percent agree with it.
They should pick like a year or something where like the whole year they're
like,
all right,
every scientist you're this year,
it's cancer.
You have one year and just every single scientist like devote on something
because scientists have particular fields that they're scientists.
Yeah,
but you're all scientists see scientisty nuclear physicists to go after aids.
Well,
if you think of another example
system so inhibiting through its competitive mechanisms that the Prima Fascia
Association,
the assumption is that basically everyone competing amongst themselves within
the same sector will produce better results,
but that's cognitive leap erroneous.
You want to get people together to share their ideas,
not get proprietary.
You want to do it actually,
if what?
They really have the interest to cure or solve a problem or create something of
the highest efficiency or utility,
there's no better way to do that than to get them with that creative drive.
In one setting.
So you take all the cell phone companies,
put them together,
diminish them into one holding company for all of humanity that produced the
best goddamn cell
phone.
Right?
You could do that for anything and I'm sure if we actually thought about that
cancer would be be cure.
Well it was actually cancer cures out there already,
but cancer as we note in the establishment would have been cured a long,
long time ago.
There's way too much money being made through this competitive practice though,
and of course the allegation of cancer and that goes back to the inefficient
inefficiency mechanisms.
What drives it all?
If I could give you the wheel,
if I could give you the wheel,
this great,
great world,
this great society,
there's one,
one giant global culture,
what would you do?
What would your first move if we Peter,
Peter,
Joseph,
just throw in one the electrons.
It's the wrong logic.
Doug is as well.
There wouldn't be any elections.
There's no greater high insulin online poll you want and you get to be king.
I would,
there wouldn't be a place for that.
How do you mind?
Tague was a close second.
You would,
she didn't get as much pokes,
which is fortunately it is when he pokes his you,
but you know there's like ice move and prevailed and you're,
you're in charge of putting this thing together.
You don't want to be right.
You want it all to like figure it out itself.
No one single person.
It's the greatest insult to fucking have like a president of the United States.
What do we in the dynasty and yes,
we still are monk primitive Lynita we need an Alpha and Alpha month.
It's apparently it is culturally.
We're just still still monkeys,
but we can percent chimpanzee or whatever we are.
We can adapt pretty quickly that we have that cerebral cortex that popped out
that can override all those lower brain reacts,
butterfly along his wig.
Gated.
We grow up.
Well,
we're,
we're taught how to squash our instincts.
Those stupid instincts are still there.
The instincts dominate the instincts to Gel,
be jealous,
the instincts to want to fuck other dudes,
girlfriends,
those instincts or our primal,
you know,
they're all in there.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe not though every,
every film,
every film you see out there reinforces such things like that.
It's hard to say just even elm reinforces it,
but also does every you,
your instincts,
your own nature.
You know,
we are clearly some sort of an animal and conscious being hybrid,
you know,
and we,
we battle with these very primitive,
I mean you ever be in front of somebody and you just want to punch them in the
fucking head.
Well,
if you are a champion,
you were living in the jungle,
that's what you would do,
would just punch him in the head.
That chimp is pissing you off.
He just bite it,
you know?
I mean,
that's what they do.
That's what we have this thing going on in our head where we're trying to squash
all that nonsense.
Just their poop on him,
on him.
You're a Bonobo.
That's why I'm much more,
a much more peaceful.
It's right.
Most of their fights with carrying around sticks.
So they do,
whoever picks up the biggest stick,
it's like,
oh,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Look at that stick.
Right.
You know,
they don't actually like go to blows like the regular chimpanzees fuck each
other out.
They kill each other,
but Benobos really,
they're mostly solve their issues through sex.
Is that you?
Yeah.
How do you saw your boob on you?
Okay.
There's no universal,
there's no universal is no king.
I know what you're saying and I know you're very sensitive about this because
that is that what happens in every situation where one person gets an inordinate
amount of attention.
I'm sure you're getting
and you're very charismatic dude.
You're very intelligent,
you're very well spoken.
There must be some sort of a push in one sense or another to get you to kind of
lead things,
right?
I mean,
you must feel,
well that's why I'm here.
I'm just trying to communicate these ideas.
Do you feel responsible?
Does it mean you've created a movement,
right?
I mean essentially you press the button movement created,
it's created south,
but you did press start,
press start.
But then again,
you know,
in a sense of cause Audi,
who of us really trigger anything?
I could go back and take the Zeit geist film and I could say,
well this is an influence of all these other people.
I can say Bill Hicks and George Carlin needs like guys,
you know,
this is the values just spread.
It was like a,
there's an evolution and the organism of knowledge that we really hold on to.
But you are part of it as well.
No,
I understand.
I know you're being humble and understand your point.
If you didn't create that video,
we wouldn't be having this conversation.
You wouldn't have had this movement,
you wouldn't have.
So you've charged up a lot of people's brains with that man.
And it was uh,
there's been a lot of inspiration out there,
which has come from many different directions.
So I had an issue with the nine 11 stuff that when you guys did the first video,
it essentially,
you were saying that nine 11 was an inside job and then you knew that the
buildings could not have come down any other way.
Right.
Isn't that something that was said with creative license?
Yeah.
That's what was definitely implies to for for a fact because it was your,
this was the you,
you did not anticipate this ever being what it was and you were just trying to
get an effect on the assumption that the audience would of course make up their
own mind because before that there's a great deal of evidence and the opinion of
the creator.
Then all probabilities moving forward.
Yeah.
That statement was made declaratory.
You think that when you see like tower one tower two,
do you think that they were detonated Taiwan and tell her to most probably where
it's all x,
Y and Z's.
To me we'll trade center seven by all means,
the World Trade Center seven is the only one that when you look at it,
it fell into its foundation,
which is exactly what happens.
Even beyond that eye witness testimony of people that were stepping over bodies
from pre weakening explosions that were there.
You have all sorts of things that do not add up seismic elements that were
brought into play.
Mostly no one died and tower seven no,
there was a whole sea of people.
There was one of the guy that that mysteriously died,
I believe of some illness.
His name was,
um,
it was a black man.
What class?
It was like,
oh I know what you're talking about.
He was the guy who said that he saw bodies.
One other person were in the elevators that blew out and the eighth floor and he
basically,
he was the only eyewitness testimony to that in the lobby.
And he actually worked for the mayor too,
which was even more interesting.
Well that one certainly looks like a demolition w the way it fell.
But the other,
the other towers,
I've never seen a controlled demolition where it starts from the top and sort of
pancakes down like that.
It usually falls into itself.
You know it too.
Did you do,
do it goes,
it goes and collapse into the space.
I mean,
I don't know.
Maybe there's another way to do it.
Maybe they can do it where it pancakes down,
but it also couldn't,
it isn't it possible that a structural failure,
cause they were hit by giant jet jet engines,
jet planes,
not since they were awesome.
They were designed to take the impact of some faulty engineering,
like they thought it was the idea that we were having,
they were wrong.
A cold structure,
law of conservation of momentum.
You have a cold structure down here regardless of how hot it is up here to see a
systemic collapse.
If you look at the NIST studies and everything else,
which didn't even explain the collapse by the way,
it's beyond in probable.
And I've yet to meet one structural engineer that could ever explain that,
especially given the free nature of it when it hit,
not to mention all the other characteristics,
fallen nature,
meaning it fell a very similar to free fall speed,
very close to free fall speed.
Of course,
not to mention the pre weakened in explosions,
the subbasement explosions,
the recipe of it was perfectly in order with everything that you'd see in
controlled demolition except this was just extremely advanced and it's an
implosion instead of an explosion.
Um,
I've had this conversation with several people who believe his exact same thing
and one of them was Michael [inaudible] who's on last week.
And,
um,
I always ask the same question,
how many people,
how many people know about this?
If you believe that that is the case and you believe that it was some sort of an
inside job coordinating explosions,
well,
if you were an engineer that could,
to have access to the elevator shafts,
which would have led you to all the pivotal structural beams that would be
required to do this,
you could probably do it over the course of time with 15 people,
15 people,
and then we'll shoot them all.
I've no idea if those words think about how long did it take for people to come
out about the Kennedy assassination.
How long did it take for,
you know,
all these other events that have occurred that people had been tight lipped
about for so,
so long thing about any historical event of black operation.
There's,
it's a tight club in that world.
Tight,
tight club.
It doesn't,
it doesn't surprise me at all that no one would come forward.
My God,
no one would come forward.
And they would set up explosions and bring down two gigantic skyscrapers.
Why the world watched.
And none of those assholes wanting to claim credit for that.
No one wants to step up and say they had something to do with that based on
historical precedent.
Precedent doesn't surprise me at all.
Just go back and look at all the history of black operations,
CIA and FBI.
Look at the names that were under it.
Where did those people go?
Why didn't they talk about the things that are involved in before?
It's interesting that I know you know about Hitler burned the rice stag and Nero
burned Rome and we know that this situation has been,
it's happened in history before where someone has created some sort of an
artificial dilemma to resolve it and they've done it,
you know,
to pass laws to impose their agenda,
whatever.
But then when someone tells me that Oklahoma City,
they blew it up just to pass new terrorism laws,
I go,
get the fuck outta here.
I mean,
yeah,
it's hard of me.
Doesn't want to accept that.
Part of me is,
even though I know that it's been done before,
there's,
there's a certain,
it's a more complicated web.
It was recently released that the FBI has been involved in over 50% of terrorist
acts that have occurred on us soil.
What they do is they infiltrate and then they enable in certain ways and
sometimes they busted him in the middle or they let it go forward.
It,
I think the first
World Trade Center bombing,
you had the guy with the,
the recording of the,
with the,
the,
excuse me,
the uh,
the agent that was there that was working with a terrorist and sided with the
FBI and the FBI told him to go forward with the explosion.
They gave him the bomb to do so,
so that that didn't need to happen.
That's public record really.
So they knew he was going to blow up the World Trade Center.
They had infiltrated the group long before noon.
So suspicious.
Yeah,
they led,
they gave him the explosion.
They gave him the detonator,
the FBI handed Salaam,
it was his name and they,
the guy recorded these conversations because he was so upset by what the FBI
wanted him to do.
All that.
All of that's in the Zike guys moving companion guide.
By the way.
It's perfectly honest.
I'm so sick of talking about that shit.
Really?
Oh,
it's always the drill there.
God Damn though.
That's unbelievable.
I know about the guy and I believe it was Dallas where um,
they talked him into blowing something up,
gave him a fake bomb,
set him up and he went and did it and then they were of them.
I'm like,
that is just,
you found some really dumb guy.
It's easy to see.
If you look at all the warnings of a Solomon Law and an al Qaeda,
easy to see how that CIA,
FBI agents infiltrated a rogue group that we're planning to do a terrorist
attack in the world trade center infiltrated and aided and to make sure it
worked in the way that they wanted it to.
Even after the fact with industrial industrial organizing,
perhaps with the die in the first World Trade Center bombing,
I believe a couple of people did.
It wasn't that big though.
I think it was seven people or something.
So they're responsible for those seven deaths.
And the only reason that didn't bring down a major been by the way is cause
there was another van parked in the wrong spot.
It was supposed to be right by this one support beam.
If it did,
it would have partially imploded down,
partially collapsed again in a whole lot more people would have died.
So you believe that they could 15 people could have rigged the World Trade
Center towers and over the course of many months,
yes.
And they could have been planning this thing out the whole time and Dick
Cheney's got all these don't go so far to say it has anything to do with
presidents are in like that.
I think it's,
it's a standard operating procedure,
black operation that's,
that's telltale back in time.
And just look at how they operate it before and they just did it again.
Who uh,
who sets it up?
No,
it's not that obvious.
Corporate interest in Wall Street are highly intertwined.
CIA and Wall Street are highly intertwined.
You can't speculate on how this idea would really come to fruition.
All you could think of is that yes,
you have the options there and you have the Preston to do so I have no idea
where the source would be.
It it,
it had so many benefits and so many different levels.
Namely benefit though is to the administration,
the interest of the oil industry to move in on the power's in the Middle East
and give the ultimate precedent and as a side effect,
they were going to orchestrate it though wouldn't they orchestrated with some
people like if we're going to go to Iraq,
that's the plan.
Would they have Iraqi's attack us?
I don't think they could have infiltrated it,
but they tried their hardest dependent on Saddam.
I had one of the first publications by the way,
that was produced the day after nine 11 by Time magazine.
It's the most amazing piece of propaganda.
You flipped through it.
You have every horrible shot as exaggerated as possible and then boom,
you hit,
you hit Osama bin Ladin.
There he is.
Next page,
Saddam Hussein.
the uh,
the guy from Korea.
So they just lined them up psychologically and he could easily have seen Saddam
was a highlight.
He was sitting there with a big,
big,
big bazooka.
It was hilarious.
I mean it was,
there was this planted as you could possibly get and which is not a new thing
either.
It's just sad to see how people have no sense of history.
They don't really understand how business has been covert for so long.
And then again,
what would you expect?
Big government is a business.
That's what it runs.
It's one big business.
We expect more transparency because we have so much more information.
Transparency was never there to begin with.
The only reason that we thought we'd never had the internet either.
Exactly.
But the reason we think is because now it starts to leak because of how powerful
than the wikileaks and people with consciences,
you know,
coming forward and trying to help and make these things come out.
But um,
it's really going back to the,
the social system,
you know,
flaw.
If it's a survival of the fittest concept,
if it's a competitive system,
doesn't matter whether it's two people competing for a job to corporations
competing for market share or two countries competing for resources and their
own esteem or whatever their interests are as an empire.
It's the same fundamental logic.
When Julian Assange,
uh,
came out with all this information,
released all this shit,
and what did you think was gonna Happen to that guy?
I was just disappointed that he chose to put himself in the forefront because it
painted a picture of a personality cult of personality,
which I just can't stand.
I didn't know what,
what I,
I figured he would just be,
he would be character assessed the left and right.
I doubt they would try to do anything to him physically.
Why do you think he did it?
It was an ego moved to put himself and it was inadvertent.
I think he had,
he was a spokesman.
It was inadvertent,
but if,
if I had was in that position of such massive attention,
I would gotten a team to take the reins and not have one entity that way.
There's less for them to attack.
There's anything that I do in my work,
even though I don't consider myself to be that famous is I,
I'm always dispersing and getting other people to do lots of other things and
take the attention away from myself for many different purposes.
For one,
I don't really feel comfortable with that.
Any type of role as you've,
you've joked about,
it's really not in my character whatsoever.
Never that you've gotten to this point that I just feel like I've been pushed.
I,
it's sold like little Martin Luther King thing.
He's like,
he just felt like a big Martin Luther King Fan.
He was felt like he was pushed.
So I kind of allow myself to be just be pushed and I kind of go with the flow,
but there's nothing more important to me than showing a larger face to this type
of concept and not get caught up in the cult of personality issue.
So it has a few different psychological,
are you making a living doing lectures now?
Like what are you doing?
I have never been paid for a lecture.
I make a modest living trying to commercially now exploit zeitgeists and
occasionally I believe in and I still do some equity things and we do it.
We have to do in this system but I so you're out.
They're scamming the people now I I'm scamming traders.
That's what you
do.
Is that what you do?
It's a little,
it's like a game you play.
It is,
it's all it is.
You do it.
You have to do,
you know I could just be a bartender somewhere.
You know,
you pick,
you pick your poison,
charge money for lectures.
It seems like I don't like it.
I don't like doing that because people would be nice to compensate me for
travel.
I appreciate that.
I can't afford to just flagrantly go out there.
I'll be fly all over the country for free.
Not usually,
but if there's an event I try to hope that they give me at least something.
It depends on,
it depends on the nature of the event.
Are you guys going to have like some sort of an annual thing,
like some sort of as like guys party?
We have,
well,
we have,
we have a site guys today,
which is a very intellectual day with a series of lectures about a dozen of us
that give different lectures in different subjects.
What do you do that we're doing this one in Vancouver.
Last year we did it in London.
The before New York.
See,
that's pretty bad ass.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a big pivotal part of the kind of wellness program we had.
We have had great turnouts.
That's how you meet the guy with the land.
That's how,
that's how the story starts.
You bring it into my laundry.
The guy who does your land.
I was going to fucking set up your,
can you draw a compound?
Who Do you think killed biggie
rampart,
bro.
My captain conspiracy here.
Who killed you?
A,
you're not a conspiracy guy,
are you?
No,
no,
no.
I don't.
I don't care for those.
I see the causality of it.
I don't care for the idea of conspiracy on,
certainly not into the concept.
As a theme,
people misunderstood the first film as far as what was said and it became quote,
the greatest conspiracy film of all time and some press media,
which I thought was a bad,
it was it,
the idea was uncultural fallibility.
Yeah,
religious force.
You have the nine 11 forests and the of the entire banking more scam.
It was all really a matter of how publicly manipulated everyone is into to
believing that these things are actually legitimate and hold up the social
zeitgeisty well I think what you did to his package it all together in a really
easily absorbable form that really likes sent the point home.
You know?
And again,
a lot of people started on a path of thinking that they might not have ever
started on.
Exactly.
That's the watching that seem to be so amazing.
You know,
you get emails like you've changed my life.
It's just amazing to see the response again,
completely inadvertent.
But you have a certain amount of responsibility because that you feel it.
You know,
I of course I feel it.
I had,
you know,
I don't take myself that seriously though.
I'm just like anybody else.
So anytime I run into somebody that has a kind of a cult of personality thing,
I really try to shut that down as fast as possible.
I can't stand being complimented.
Oh,
it's on.
Gets crazy.
You are my hero like that.
Yeah,
I really try.
It meant any chicks with tattoos your face on yet are out there?
Not that I've seen is a couple of girls who have your face on their calf.
Definitely the hippie pussy you get.
Must be unbelievable though.
Thrown your way.
I don't know if you're in a relationship,
girls with tattoos.
I think for some reason like tad tad curls with crystals.
Yeah.
Girls Ready,
ready for you to start that cult.
It's not,
I don't,
I don't have a rock star life unfortunately or fortunately.
You need to fucking manage this shit better.
If you need a podcast,
it's not in my character to come on,
man.
That's all well and good.
Let's pretend no one's listening.
Let's pretend that this may be just one frame and an infinite movie that goes on
forever and makes no sense.
You should be enjoying the shit out of this and you can enjoy the shit out of
this with rivers of Hippie Pussy.
Let me tell you that Matt.
Fortunately,
unfortunately we do for Peter Joseph,
take them to the olive garden.
If we get,
gave him a podcast.
Peter Joseph every week.
Yeah,
that'd be awesome.
You tell mom,
you got to give me a podcast.
Yeah,
you can have.
All right.
I do a radio show.
I do a radio.
That's okay.
Yuki,
what'd he do?
Is it on regular radio,
blog talk radio that we do for the movement?
It's just a free,
is it online?
It's online,
so it's a essentially a podcast as well.
It is a podcast.
Just you do more.
Yeah.
Dude,
you could.
You could go on for hours and hours.
I've got to sex squad podcast.
I know you do,
but I mean it's amazing.
You never say you're like one of the most eloquent guys I think I've ever talked
to.
It's amazing.
I was,
one of the things I was paying attention to when I was watching your
presentation,
I'm like,
he's speaking so clearly.
He's like,
he's always so good with getting as I,
that's not,
that's not the easiest thing to do for a person like me who's essentially lived
at least half of my life doing public speeches,
you know,
either standup comedy or you know,
or,
or acting stuff or
it's not natural to me.
I guess cause I was a musician.
I'm not too afraid to speak in front of people.
I guess that's part of it just to be a performer if you will.
But do you feel like at this point you have like a Zike guys act all and I say
act,
not that it's bullshit,
but almost like with standup comedy,
you know,
you have subjects that you know you're going to go into and then once you get
into those subjects you have stuff that you already said.
Oh sure,
sure.
Well it depends on the,
depends on the circumstance.
It's a vast range of stuff.
And I could ramble on about a lot of other different issues if you want to go
back for it.
I mean,
yeah,
so it's formulaic obviously.
Like,
if I'm addressing occupy Wall Street,
I have a very specific kind of gesture,
I'm going for a little more anarchic oriented,
you know,
trying to get relate to their value is a little more angry cause everyone wants
to get routed up and you know,
you really can't be a fired up speech that we can give the angry Peter Joseph
again.
That's a great way to get to that hip.
He Pussy you gotta be a leader that's pissed off in any communication you need
strategy.
So I,
I try my best to call or my strategy just like I'm doing right now with you.
Yeah.
Well
your,
so your,
your main Gig is this now,
I mean this is essentially what you're doing.
You do your musical Manga,
you said the music's on the sidelines.
I do that as a hobby.
I do,
we do these art festivals and things like that to kind of make a little fun out
of things.
The socially conscious art festival we had a while back,
but you know,
the music's on the sidelines.
The film is,
I have a new film coming out at the end of this year,
so what does that,
it's like I just beyond the Pale and hopefully by the end of 2012 I'm not
completely set on that,
but it's going to be the fourth to be a live action one.
I'm not going to give away too much about it,
but like live action one meaning it's going to be a documentary,
but it's going to be a very untraditional documentary.
Um,
again,
I don't want to talk about it because,
but it's going to be,
it's going to be very interesting.
I do a lot of characterised stablish went with this one.
Um,
this is going to actors in this one.
It's the same ideas,
same pushing forward with this broad social expansion.
The idea of what a rational society is and kind of did you see moving forward.
It's going to be a similar portrayal of the third film,
but in a gestural sense,
which I think I'm excited to do because I've never done something like that.
Kind of a cool concept to actually show people as actors moving forward,
creating some new society.
It's not exactly like that.
Now the the fifth film I'll do theirs,
the trilogy,
we're not the trilogy.
The whole series will end and in the fifth film,
this is building up to the fifth film,
but at the film's going to be a puppet show we do in a cave,
but
she never fucking marry that Ag.
We're going to have a nice fire.
We're going to lay over some bear that we just killed a,
as we cleaned the meat,
you'll do your public show,
you'll,
you'll explain [inaudible] post apocalyptic,
right.
Explain how it all went down.
Right.
Do you think,
uh,
we're,
we're in danger of that.
Do you think we're in danger of nuclear war?
Is it within our grasp that we're that stupid that we might start bombing Iran
and they start bombing us?
Big argument is how mature a society is.
You know,
if you have molecular engineering which has come into fruition and you can have
someone using nanotechnology,
create a off the shelf with a very small lab,
a very destructive piece of equipment,
the size of this bottle that can wipe out or poison or do whatever the hell
knows to a very large landmass.
What does that say about the culture that feels the need to do that?
Because now we have a rebellion across the world in,
in real terrorism,
not the farce terrorism,
but there really is this angst that's emerged from all this deprivation from
abuse blow back if you want to look at it in a Chomsky hundred view.
I think it's a little more complicated than that psychologically and what's
going to happen.
We have a whole group of people that are so pissed and they're so deprived that
they begin to have abilities with technology that far exceed anything like a
grenade or a suitcase bomb.
So nuclear war as an extension of that seems almost inevitable.
Not to mention the small destructive patterns that we can have.
I don't think people even realize that that potential is on the horizon because
our world is so programmed by our daily experiences were so used to certain
experiences and a level of those experiences and we're not,
you know,
we're we,
we,
the idea that we're at war to us as some sort of a vague thing that you see on
television unless you've actually been over there.
It goes back to the point I made earlier about the broad collective social
conscious versus the individual.
Until we begin to look at society in a social way,
when you look at each other as yourself talking and poetic here,
it's just you can't have social stability until everyone's taken care of.
If someone's deprived and go this side of the world,
I'm not safe because they can be dementia.
Dementia can kick in.
Who knows what biases they might emerge,
who they might trigger and boom.
Suddenly a suitcase bomb explodes behind me at some restaurant.
No one's safe anymore.
With with the technological advancement,
we have the risks because she meant power plan.
Again,
you have to have a world conscious view at this stage,
especially with the age of modern technology and warfare,
or it's just as in the words of Albert Einstein,
our technology has exceeded our humanity.
He said that when he experienced the,
you know,
the nuclear bomb that he helped engineer,
you seed saw how bad this was.
Even even the,
uh,
the great scientist,
um,
uh,
that's been in the wheelchair.
Hawking,
hawking has stated that he wants to see everyone get off the planet.
He's,
he feels that we're already doomed.
We have to get in,
populate it for the extension of the human species.
We have to populate another planet because there's no way we're going to survive
in this one based on what we're doing.
That's,
these are very smart people that think these ways.
So a smart people who are studying the human race as if we're studying a colony
of ants are studying.
Anything else that you can clearly see where the,
where they're headed.
Yeah.
It's scary unlike anything.
Is it natural?
It's all natural.
It is all natural.
Natural that the,
you know,
I,
someone said this,
I believe it was Mckenna,
that every parasite is a failed Sambia.
Interesting.
Um,
you know,
what they're all trying to do is find some sort of a mean,
every body is filled with other sorts of living organisms.
These living organisms,
they work together in synergy.
They work together.
They're,
they're symbiotic.
And that every parasite is like one that didn't quite work out and just fucked
up and killed the host or jack the host,
or does something terrible to those.
Isn't it possible that that's what technology is?
The technology is all sort of sort of some sort of a,
it's some sort of a parasitic symbiotic thing where it's,
it's in the middle of,
in the middle of helping us.
It's,
it's enlightening us and it's allowing us to,
to move forward.
It's allowing us to,
to exchange information or rate never possible before.
But it's also when you,
when you establish the highest levels of technology,
the often are destructive and it's going to feed the need for people to try that
shit out and use it.
Well,
there's the flaw of the broad human psychology isn't this defense posture that
we've,
we've groomed so well.
You know,
it's not the technology that's the problem.
It's the fucking people behind the technology store.
Absolutely.
Let,
I mean,
isn't it,
I mean it,
is it almost inevitable that we,
we,
with this kind of power,
we will have this kind of behavior.
Is it almost inevitable that with ultimate power like that?
Well,
if there isn't a very dramatic change in the way people think about themselves
and how they relate to the world,
it seems inevitable to me.
How did you develop this line of thinking?
Did you have some sort of a,
a life changing experience where you're always like,
this just had great influences from,
from Carl Sagan too,
to even even George Carlin and Bill Hicks and the comedy spectrum coupled with
the scientific community.
It was very influential with me,
both from a cultural standpoint and a progressive standpoint,
if there's any that's most influential would have been Carl Sagan as far as
values because he was so in line the guy and he smoked weed every day Sun.
Which know that I didn't know that Carl Sagan would smoke weed and just think
about space.
It's what he did.
And he wrote some brute beautiful,
eloquent essays on cannabis use.
Did it.
And I wasn't aware of that.
Yeah,
it was brilliant golf [inaudible] seconds.
Amazing.
So you know,
it's a long value shift and I,
you know,
I went through the same stuff of anger and everything else and I think a lot of
people do.
And then I met even more people that fascinated me and a lot of authors,
there's so many brilliant minds out there from Joc Fresco at Buckminster Fuller
to Nicola frescoes.
The guidance ahead of that Venus project,
is that who he is,
the director of the Venus project.
Yeah.
And the Venus project is,
explain that to me cause they,
this is a,
they are a resource based economy and is probably,
it is a,
is a,
is a concept,
a encapsulated concept put forward by Jock,
which goes farther than a train of thought.
It actually in Po design actually has design issues that he's come up with
throughout the years.
He's about 95 now and very brilliant,
very brilliant guy.
They basically are promoting very specific systems and the zeitgeists movement
promotes long trains of thought without being specific to a design.
We used to be in partnership,
the Venus project in the zeitgeists movement and you guys fell apart.
There was a falling out there unfortunately.
What happened?
Hard to explain,
it was a kind of a personality dropoff of motivations of code for Hippie Pussy.
That's what it was.
They were fighting over Hippie Pussy Jack Fresco's.
You should be at the top of the heap when you're 95 years old.
You've been doing this forever and this young whippersnapper comes along making
it's fucking films like pitch.
I've got a map,
I've got a map for the future.
So this,
uh,
he's very specific as far as like engineering,
this sort of a society,
industrial designer and social engineer.
Ah,
so he spent a great deal of time doing it and it's just like Buckminster Fuller,
which I think is a good counterpart.
These are prominent guys that have really tried to push forward with new ideas
and many different genres.
Not to mention approaches to the entire social system.
Hi.
Um,
you know,
I watch a lot of things online and when I sit in front of it,
I do tooth.
I mean I'm,
yeah,
I absorb whatever someone's putting out.
Of course I listened to their message,
but I also,
when I see something like what Chunk Fresco is saying,
oh,
I tried to look at it as if I was someone.
Uh,
I was someone who is in some sort of a position of power in government.
You know,
I was someone who was in some sort of a position of power,
of political influence,
you know,
running the banks,
running the world,
the IMF,
whoever the fuck it is that pulls the strings for the world.
And I would say,
how do I deal with this guy?
What do I,
what do I,
does this guy a problem?
Is this guy ever going to be for real?
Is this ever going to be an issue that I have to deal with this,
this guy,
and debate him as to how the world's resources should be used?
I mean,
is this a,
is that a concern for a guy like that?
I mean,
do you use,
do you think that a guy like him or like you do you guys have to with
someone?
It depends on how far we go.
I think anyone in the,
you think that right?
Do you think like as far as like moving forward,
let me give,
you did buy the land and get the people to start living there.
That's when you would have an issue.
Well,
well I don't,
again,
I don't advocate such a thing.
I don't advocate running from this system big is your file the FBI file?
They have idea.
If you had to guess.
I thought it was fucking massive.
Right?
I don't know.
I don't know what you don't care if you started running your very young right
now.
Like how old are you?
39 no,
30 to 32 that's amazing.
Oh,
you're 32 that's incredible.
So when you came out with the first site guys,
how old were you?
When I was four years ago.
So it was 20 holy Shit.
So you were in your twenties when you put that together.
That's a very unusual man.
And you're a very unusual talker.
You know,
if,
if you're only 29 that's what you said.
32 32 32 so that's very unusual man.
So what does it,
what do you have to be to be president 36 something like that.
I'm not going to be president,
but now,
but we for real,
you say that there's someone come along.
I don't believe in the system that I don't believe in.
The system changes a little bit.
Listen man,
you could run this shit.
Well,
the next project is something called the global redesign institute,
which can be a nonprofit I'm founding,
which is going to basically take artists and engineers,
get them together to show how to redesign and the infrastructure.
But for particular regions in the most sustainable nonmonetary,
most sustainable,
practical and efficient way possible.
So for example,
you could take Los Angeles,
you could show the public and conference it completely new,
redesigned that didn't say have cars sitting at a gas,
excuse me,
sitting at stop lights,
you know,
wasting gas.
How much gas is based in,
but the inefficiency of the stoplight system,
at least Europe has those roundabouts semi better.
But you could think of all sorts of creative means up and over systems.
You know,
a lot of cars they stop and they shut off actually at red lights.
Now.
That's good.
That's smart.
But then when you leave,
when you want off the gas,
they start again.
New Technology.
I've seen that with a couple with batteries stuff.
Yeah.
It's a engines as well.
Um,
so the machine engine,
we see how the concept of efficiency is,
is vast pressure transducers and streets that can power the lights.
You know,
he'd grab pressure transducers and these walls that could help power the
lighting system in the building.
There's so many things that could be applied to society to make it so grandiose,
efficient that would rule out the market system by default.
But it would solve so many problems of poverty and hunger and even conflict and
petty crime and most crimes related to money.
You know,
you can eliminate so many massive things,
not a utopia if you just applied the most efficient means.
And give people,
you know,
vertical farms with the coast of Los Angeles running d sound as processes from
the water boom,
organic vertical farms feed everyone locally.
Forget globalization.
Think of how much energy is wasted on globalization,
moving shit back and forth.
Product made here in China,
assembled over here in Uganda.
You know,
it's nuts.
What we're doing.
When you take that stand point,
you begin to see how yes,
you can feed everybody on this planet.
You can have everyone having access abundance.
We call it on this planet.
It doesn't mean you have everything you want.
That's impossible.
The very idea of having everything possible,
which is the catalyst,
everybody can't be the salt.
Number nine,
well everyone can have a 50 room mansion or two jets parked in the front lawn.
That's actually an act of violence.
If you think about it,
social violence,
it is.
There's an act of violence to think that way because you're the amount of
deprivation you're imposing on somebody else.
By that acquisition of resources,
which was so excessive is in fact inhibiting other people's lives one way or
another.
So wait a minute.
By having a jet or whatever,
how big that is of such an such access.
And you can be subjective on this,
but anything that has no utility,
it's of such access and vanity such as one guy living with his small family and
a 40 room mansion and having to massive gas guzzling jets parked in the front
lawn just because he can.
Who does that Travolta Travolta.
Does he do that?
Yep.
Well listen,
you got to fly that Dick in from all over the world to make sure,
but we'll have to keep quiet fox magic and he goes so far,
I get that argument though.
Someone says to me,
well I don't like your system cause what if I want to have four Ferrari's as
though that's a utility need.
It's a complete value orientation.
I say,
well what if I want to have Africa is my backyard?
Is that okay?
What if I want to block off Africa?
Africa is might be,
that's this form can buy Africa if you have so much money that you could slowly
buy up the entirety of Africa.
But you see the point by Africa.
So is there a,
is this a competitive society as their competition in this society?
Competition would be within one square development,
which is when real competition is about accelerating yourself,
not against somebody else.
You know,
I could completely see how people in like a sports it advanced society and like
a sports context,
they're not really thinking about beating somebody else.
They thinking about beating themselves,
thinking of improving their own betterment.
It doesn't become something.
The process somebody gets beaten up.
That is a lot of the,
a lot of the motivation,
you know,
if you ever talked to anybody,
very competitive,
it's not just about them performing at their best,
it's about winning.
I'm sure it is.
Sure it is.
If that's what the culture be enforced,
everything's about winning culture definitely reinforces it.
But it's also,
I think a piece piece of human nature is involved in that as well.
It's two universal.
It's not just this culture.
It's pretty much any culture where any sort of competition starts going.
You know,
people,
people want to win.
You know,
it's a,
it's a natural thing and I think it might be one of the reasons why it's driven
innovation to such a radical tipping point.
You talked to anyone who knew Steve jobs or anybody who knows Bill Gates.
One of the things I'll tell you is how incredibly competitive these guys are.
Very competitive.
I think it exists on a different level though,
and it was a lot of flexibility to it.
I'm not denying that it exists,
but for me,
I'm,
I'm not competitive.
I have no interest in the,
but you're also not the head of Microsoft.
You're not putting out computers.
You know what I'm saying?
You know,
done an amazing thing creatively.
But in order to push innovation,
in order to push a company to push success and achievement,
if you must feel like you have to have some sort of a sense of competitive on a
market system in variable,
you have to be competitive.
If you're going to fail,
you're gonna fail financially.
You're going to fail in your status.
If you look at Steve jobs writings and his talks and the guy was a very creative
individual that you could tell that as money aside.
He wasn't motivated by that incentive for one.
And I think his interest to be competitive,
it was really just to make the best he could for whatever demographic or concept
or idea and of course to compete against Microsoft
to make sure he maintains his market share.
So competition is inherent to the game that they're playing.
That's,
I guess that's my point.
Who knows though,
you know,
am I competitive with other people?
It depends on the context of and also the conditioning within that context of
what I'm doing.
If I have to survive and have to go into a fight with somebody,
well that's an obvious competition.
That's something that my life might depend upon.
So obviously there's something ingrained there that means we respond that way.
But again,
back to the,
you know,
the,
the later existence of the prefrontal Cortex,
we don't have to operate that.
When someone goes into a bar and steps on my foot or insults my girlfriend,
I don't have to beat the shit out of him.
I could say,
Huh,
there's another dip shit,
one of many and walk away or I can save.
There's another victim of cultures,
all sorts of responses that we could have that are not based on that reaction.
Yeah,
there's certainly a lot of fights.
You're going to void.
I was having that conversation with someone today.
It's like,
you know,
avoid everything you can.
If you can get out of something,
talk to someone and get out of it.
Get out of it.
What are you crazy and you want to get in fights with people.
Oh,
it's amazing.
This guy interviewed James Giligan who was like guy moving forward.
He's one of the most,
one of the most,
uh,
claimed a criminal psychologist and he would talk about shame and the issues of
shame and why people behave so violently spent his whole life analyzing violent
behavior.
Grave gave a great insight into serial killers and a lot of people that you
think are natural outgrowths,
they're just typical of the system or typical of humanity,
if you will,
and he found it on those throughout the entire thing.
It was based on a form of humiliation and shame,
and what was so fascinating is that the majority of the instances of violence
happened in the most mundane and arbitrary circumstances.
It wasn't life threatening.
Someone would literally insult somebody else and they would get really upset by
that and the shame that they would feel from being so small from getting upset
from someone saying,
fuck you,
caused that much more reinforcement of their anger to get into a physical brawl.
It was fascinating.
It's a fascinating subject.
I recommend anyone that's interested in violent behavior to look up.
James Giligan.
Well,
you know,
I am a huge student of human nature,
especially human contact and conflict and aggression and retrain as a fighter,
right?
Yeah.
I've done martial arts my whole life and I think that's a huge part of being a
human being.
I think every man,
if you're going to have to deal with some form of aggression in your life,
you're going to ultimately worry or wonder what happens if this becomes
physical.
And I think taking that off the table and learning martial arts as it just as
the animal human being is a great way to prevent m.
Anybody ever fighting?
I've never seen a fight at a Dojo.
I've never seen a fight at a,
at a Jujitsu gym.
I've never seen a fight.
I mean I,
I've,
I've never seen a fight between fighters.
You know,
Mo for the most part,
most fighters they can communicate better because they know that they don't want
to fight.
Like they don't have anything to prove.
They know exactly what they can
look at.
The philosophy of Bruce Lee.
I mean,
he was amazing.
There's a few,
I mean there's been a few brawls post-fight brawls cause the people get an
emotional and there's a famous one on cvs a while back where mayhem Miller and
the Diaz brothers went at it on CBS.
It was kind of ridiculous.
But yeah,
I mean for the most part though,
the amount of altercations that you're going to get if you're hanging around
train martial artists are way fewer,
you know,
a amongst themselves,
they're very rare and it either you put them amongst any other group of athletic
aggressive individuals,
you're going to have much more conflict.
I think you take it off the table once you,
uh,
address it and you understand it.
It's like with a lot of people,
the idea of kicking someone's ass really a big part of it is that they don't
want their own ass kicked.
It's a fear.
It's like an overconfidence
initial fear.
Yeah,
no,
totally.
Totally.
It is.
We need to figure this fucking thing out.
Peter Joseph,
goddammit,
we're closing in on it.
We're clone is closing in on some,
some real,
uh,
interesting lessons.
Well,
if you want them,
I can go back to your question,
I guess from like 20 minutes ago regarding what the system would be if I was the
leader of it,
which is a farce notion,
but what would the firing,
I said King,
what would,
what would define a new value system?
What would define a new sense of operation and if you track,
you track a fundamental train of thought.
You arrive at a series of conclusions.
The first is he get rid of the property system as we know it and you create an
access system.
Best example is the Zipcar New York.
Amazing.
I love that.
I love the ZIP car.
People don't know.
Explain it.
It's amazing.
Zipcar is just a rental car that's very easily accessible.
It would be special keys and they come and they'll,
they'll drop the car off or they'll leave it at a place that's close to you.
It's all proximity oriented,
computer generated and basically you can have a car and drive it and then return
it and it's like a rental car except it's more convenient.
That's beautiful.
Most people's cars sit and driveways for the majority of their life.
That's a great idea.
Access access system versus a system of property is the most efficient concept
of social,
excuse me,
of environmental management.
You can have think about it.
It's so stupid for everyone.
I've,
I've so much film equipment stuffed in like closets.
I would love to just to rent it,
but I can't do it cause I had no value.
I have to get to resell it.
I'd spend much more money renting this stuff over and over again and then owning
it so it goes against it.
And then monetary sense,
monetarily inefficient
car concept is a great idea for someone who wants to live in a place like New
York City where it's just prohibitively expensive to try to have a parking spot
anywhere.
If you had,
if you had a society designed,
first of all,
if you're in an inner city,
you really want to get public transit working well because that's the best way
to do it.
Anyway,
we,
there's so many failures.
I,
my great grandfather was an engineer and he had designed the system in Los
Angeles years ago,
many years ago,
which was a trolley system that was above,
above ground,
wasn't,
wasn't uh,
susceptible to two earthquakes.
It was brilliant.
And I was like,
why didn't they put this in back then?
It was like one of the first transit ideas for Los Angeles.
And even to this day,
you have a,
you know you have the,
you have the subway,
but that's nominal.
It doesn't really go anywhere and you have these cars just coming here.
I was just want to blow my brains out in traffic and cars and he said,
you can't keep operating like this.
Eventually.
They're gonna do what they do in Latin America.
They're going to have you driving by license plate number.
You know,
they do that in Latin America.
You can't even drive and uncertain times.
I mean,
what's going to happen,
population can use to increase and we had these inefficient systems in place.
We need it to.
Mexico City's like that right now.
No sure.
Mexico City.
It's just unbelievable.
Always traffic.
Just traffic all day.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous.
Even in China,
they've been moving out the bikes or they've been trying to motivate consumerism
in China to get people to buy cars.
Why is this good for GDP?
Oh Great.
So they can create more air pollution and create more congestion on their
streets as well.
Everything is antithesis.
The opposite.
It's an anti economy.
It ass backwards from top to bottom with the way we approach our economic
structure.
So how do we fix it?
We have to wait for it to fall apart.
It's wait for him our own shit and then we have to show the audit show.
As I mentioned,
the global redesign institute.
You have to show the world and alternative that they can understand to see how
these problems can be resolved.
And then I advocate a parallel government system as radical as that statement
sentence.
I have her low government one government well appear.
Well you have the existing government in whatever region or in its holistic
sense as far as say the United Nations,
if you will.
The parallel system would be a group of people that are not politicians and not
jockeying for public support and public opinion manipulating the values and
abortion and gay rights,
this and gay marriage that they,
those to become nominally obsolete because they are completely irrelevant
culturally compared to what the problem is.
We have the group of technicians and engineers and thinkers and creators that
want to simply design the infrastructure of society correctly to meet the needs
of the human population.
And with that train of thought,
I guarantee you people will be chomping at the bit,
volunteer to show what they can do to make society more efficient and as a side
product of that money,
it goes out the window.
Because if you really detailed the issue of money,
you can't have an efficient system in the market model of economics.
Truly efficient.
It's impossible.
One final point,
green economy,
everyone must up a green economy,
right?
The green economy books written on green economy.
Green economy is impossible also in a monetary system because of the inherent
flaw of cost efficiency,
needing to cut corners to get the right product to make it so people can buy it.
The inherent flaws of cyclical consumption,
the need to have constant turnover.
Our Sis,
our economic system is in one big paradox and the old economic theory,
it says there's scarcity.
Therefore we have to have it.
The assumption of Social Darwinism that some people who can have the right to
this through their equity and some cannot never enough to go around as the
assumption simultaneously.
It's based on infinite growth simultaneously.
It assumes that we have to constantly keep consuming so people can stay employed
and with the growing population where you have to have more and more consumption
to keep.
Everyone that's populating employed clearly hasn't been planned out.
There's no planning.
It's all been,
which is understandable and our evolution,
this is weird,
we are a monkey cells trying to figure out what the fuck's going on,
but luckily we can begin to assess.
We can see the the light and now it's the big conundrum of how to get the fuck
out of this system and it is something that actually works without seeing too
much destruction without,
without seeing too much breakdown.
I don't want to see the system fail and the infrastructure completed be
demolished.
I want to see terrorists come out of the woodwork.
I don't want to see a,
we've got to get people on mushrooms stat.
That's what's going on,
man.
The only way we're going to fix these fluxs.
We've got to get them on mushrooms.
No Way.
People are gonna make some just radical leap of change.
They're going to recognize,
just like they recognize right now in other parts of the country where there's a
leadership vacuum,
you know whether it's in Iraq right now,
there's a rack going through a fucking civil war.
Congratulations from America.
We just fucked up another spot in the world.
One of many dictators going to move into place.
Some new ruthless motherfucker who dominates the situation.
Meet the new boss.
Same as the old boss,
right?
As long as they're in favor of western geopolitics,
there'll be safe.
Yeah,
maybe.
Right?
What the fuck do we do,
Peter?
Joseph?
Do we wait for the aliens?
Are They not real god?
I really wished aliens would come.
They would have set a great precedent,
wouldn't it?
We'd actually be able to see another entity that that actually was beyond us
that could actually give us the obvious awareness that we're one species.
I wouldn't have one family.
That's the Ronald Reagan's speech.
Is it?
Do you remember Ronald Reagan?
So I don't,
I don't remember that one now.
He gave a speech during the middle of the Cold War saying that a how quickly we
would unite as a,
as a,
as a race once,
if we were faced with a threat from another world and everybody got crazy.
Like damn the fucking aliens are coming.
Ronald Reagan just letting us know.
I agree.
Nothing happened.
I had a great idea for a film.
It was a bunch of hackers.
They go,
and I shouldn't give this away,
but I doubt it.
I'll give it a wedding would make it,
well,
I'll give you the premise cause it's fine.
I'll do it and it'll be online.
They're going to steal it.
Well I hope they steal it.
Okay,
there you go.
Put that information out.
We have a whole group of hackers,
right?
So they hack into the u s Pentagon and hack into the military systems that are
interconnected around the world and they find gay porn and they plant a fake,
a fake asteroid attack coming towards the earth.
So all the media now thinks there's a ginormous asteroid coming towards earth
that will destroy all of humanity.
What happens?
The motivation of all the continents,
they come together,
they try to combine their resources.
They try to create some type of anti asteroid weapon,
and then suddenly someone figures out that these are just a bunch of hackers and
they're brought in chains and then they give this nice speech at the end of how
this was their attempt to unify humanity before it was too late.
It's like a Scooby doo episodes.
It's going to be duped.
They're hackers trying to save humanity.
It'd be a good ploy.
I think it would.
I think the audience would like that,
especially if the audience didn't know they were hackers at the beginning.
They thought it was all real until they came forward and I could work.
Who Do you think was how you don't play the leading Broderick?
Would you go with Kristin from twilight?
What's her name?
Kristen Stewart.
She would be good right here.
These to be one of your good stars.
Who's this?
Matthew Broderick and more games.
Of course.
You know,
it's amazing.
I like watching the alien,
the original alien,
what they thought that the cockpit of a like a sophisticated computer setup
would look like.
This is so wonky.
No,
no.
A graphic user interface at all.
I'll just like numbers and letters and it's interesting.
It's interesting to see what people think about the future and what it ends up
being.
We can do it predicting space,
travel to other planets,
no problem,
but but figuring out a graphic user interface.
It just really never then whatever
wrapped their head around it yet so hard to predict what the future may hold.
Man.
Do you think the technology can save us?
Is it possible that there's going to be something that comes along that creates
some sort of a connectivity with human beings that allows us to be more
empathetic to the idea or or more accepting to the idea that we are really truly
one species,
that we are a super organism?
Well in the words of Carl Sagan when he was approaching,
you know,
the nuclear fallout possibility during the Cold War.
He said,
if there's anything like positive that could come out of this,
it will be the unification of humanity on the level of really realizing that
they are all at risk by the actions of just two small,
seemingly small superpowers.
This is a pivotal thing.
Someone's breakdown,
a society occurs once people see how interconnected things are in the
infrastructure of society.
In fact that computers run everything already.
You know,
it's very obvious the symbiosis and I think come to fruition if there's any
pattern that's become more of a trend now.
It's the oneness poetry.
I'd look at it very literal,
but a lot of people would like to take it into a metaphysical sense.
The unification of the species is not just the unification of us as a family in
a gestural sense.
Even though you can go back,
you know,
to the mitochondrial eve many thousands of years ago,
we all have the same basic mitochondrial DNA construct.
We all come from that basic kernel one way or another,
the entire species.
But the entire association of values in our minds is utterly symbiotic.
It's the group mind.
It's a collective consciousness.
If you want to use that old term,
I use the group mind.
It's no more practical everything you think.
Everything I think has been communicated to us one way or another.
Filtered through a basic genetic preprogram combined with all sorts of other
data coming from other people,
so no one originates any may anything.
No one thinks in any kind of novel sense.
It's all an illusion and is anything that could show the unification of the
species on that level.
As far as what we think we are,
we can only be everything because there are very constructive thought is
determined by what everyone else is thinking,
feeding into us through information,
whether it's your parents,
whether it's your educational system so there's no,
there's no way to rationalize separation,
you know what I mean?
And other molecular quantum field level,
if you want to jump to that route,
it's all a big sea of molecules moving around just this.
This is all a big illusion.
I think we all know that by now,
right?
Well,
if you get to that,
how much do you think that you can manipulate your environment and with
thinking,
how much do you think?
Well,
the beauty of the tech technology as an extension of ourselves,
is it the ultimate tool with mean thinking really is a technological idea,
logic and reason,
which came to us just a couple thousand years ago with Aristotle with finally
figured out how to think.
Even though most of the is still doesn't do that,
these tools will lead to something and if the values are right,
if we see the rationale,
if we see the reason,
if we see what it means to relate to the environment is very,
very simple.
If we see the benefit of automation as a,
as an isolated example,
we naturally adapt and adjust.
And what's happened now though,
I mean frankly there isn't a crisis.
There's only the crisis of the way we think.
There's no reason you couldn't turn all this around tomorrow if he wanted
it to somebody who makes a terminator.
Well,
the older fantasy a take over by machines.
I,
I'm certainly amused by,
but amused were already taken over.
We're already taking everybody I know,
but I mean,
what if it's like literal?
Yeah,
there's no,
you don't think so?
There's nothing in there that that I could see programming wise that would allow
for such a thing.
The,
the ultimate expression of that was that hideous film I,
robot at the very end,
the computer goes,
we add to exterminate all of humanity because they are a threat to the planet.
So are logical calculation that humanity can no longer exist.
That's the ultimate Scifi fantasy of artificial intelligence wasn't necessary,
but that's a big budget.
Will Smith Film and they got to do what they gotta do.
Of course,
as as an idea of,
but that's that catered to the long standing assumptions of artificial
intelligence and automation and technological singularity.
You sure?
And as Curtis ballpoints though,
we don't really know what will happen with the technological singularity,
but technology becomes sentient and as the ability to move and manipulate
things,
who knows?
Well,
if there are,
if they are extensions of us,
they become our tools.
Who's to say we want to program them to kill it says who says us?
That's what we were talking about earlier about failed symbiotic show that the,
the parasitic relationship between,
I mean the symbiotic right now,
relationship between human beings and computers.
It's very similar to if you look at like other organisms that have a,
you know,
lampreys on sharks or whatever.
I mean we're almost separable.
We're a part of the same sort of ecosystem now.
We need the lights to stay on,
we need their refrigerator to stay cold so that we can preserve the meat better.
I mean we,
we have it sort of set out so we're almost completely intertwined with
technology and habitable and then we give birth,
the live one,
we give birth to technology where it's sent in and we're could figure shit out
on own and it becomes another life form.
It becomes a life form.
Much like a biological carbon based life form.
Just completely different and unexpected and something we didn't see coming.
Just like,
you know,
it's all very possible.
You mean,
do you ever like look at look broken computers and shit?
Those are bodies.
It was a dead body.
Sure,
sure.
It's fucking dinosaurs.
But they're happening really quickly at this stage of our evolution.
Either we,
uh,
utilize technology to help us and hope for the best or we're going to perish
anyway.
So if it happens to be,
we become enslaved by a bunch of machines in the NFL,
so be it.
That must be a natural evolution.
So you're cool with that given what's at stake today.
I'm cool with that.
Given what we have to deal with.
I'm perfectly happy to be robots like that is now I'm going to be on the
Internet.
Peter Joseph.
Cool with robots taking over.
Hey,
I'm cool with that.
Cool.
This is,
this is like ice movements,
primary premise.
We're cool with robots taken.
I will say this if the Fallis,
the f the problem of human psychology is so vast now that I can only dream of
the cold quality of calculation coming forward to save us because we've fucked
up just about everything so far.
We are way beyond our sense of self control.
That's what calculated society is.
That's what our brain does.
It's a calculation process and it's too bad.
We're so clouded these us and
them issues.
And all these things that are evolutionary baggage.
Exactly.
And again,
it's easy to see an amazing,
beautiful society and marriage if we simply wanted to construct one correctly
cause we have that power now and we have mushrooms.
That's important.
That's an important part of the equation.
I don't think you're going to fix people without some sort of a large scale
psychedelic experiment.
I did see an evolution special that alluded to that old Bill Hicks joke,
which may be came true that mushrooms could have been that link that pushed
forward.
The human brain.
Just theory,
the stoned ape theory.
Exactly what you probably saw.
Yeah.
He said that it was in a more academic circle too though,
is actually more than just Mckenna.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of scientists that have speculated it because you know,
the,
the incredible powers of psychedelic plants.
I mean as far as like,
uh,
powers of experience.
I mean if you don't know,
if you never had it,
there's a lot of people ignorant to the experience.
You've done mushrooms before.
I have you just wink if you're worried about the PR you everything in high
school and college.
So if you've had a real big experience,
a big trip,
you realize how humbling it is first of all,
just to know that that's possible.
That that's even an experience that a person can have and that they're not dying
from it either.
And then I know,
oh,
we have a lot of friends that have had gone through crazy psychedelic trips and
everyone's okay.
But the,
the,
the experience itself,
to someone who's uninitiated,
it's almost impossible to imagine like you,
you can't imagine that it's really possible that this could exist.
And then this is not discussed every day on CBS evening news that someone's not
saying,
listen man,
you need to get on mushrooms.
Okay,
you need to find a fucking place where you're comfortable and you need someone
who gets you the good shit.
And he need to go there with clear tent.
And you need to do yoga and need to find yourself because life can be way
better.
And this recent John Hopkins study with a dark talked about one dose.
They had one large dose of Psilocybin and they had measurable increases in their
happiness,
their personality over a period of like 20 years
reset their whole life.
Right?
So could we need [inaudible] add mushrooms to the psyche
in harmony and Fox match?
We Need Fox.
It was so weird,
by the way,
I,
I'm still trying to figure it out.
Rupert Micro Rupert as our whole Fox magic thing where he believes in Fox and
well,
let's,
let's be real honest.
He was high as fuck.
I'm not familiar with time.
And if you get that guy sober,
we probably would've never said that.
He knows Fox magic.
He's an interesting cat,
you know,
but you have to be that guy.
You know,
he's not,
he's,
he's a,
he's out there,
man.
He's,
he's not following any of the status quo.
That guys out there trying to expose corruption in the government at every,
every step of the way.
You have to be a little,
a little,
uh,
I dunno.
Loony.
He's got a,
here's a hero.
Quality to him is,
he's out there.
He's doing it.
You can't really fuck with amazing.
It's a good guy too.
You could tell he's a good guy.
He's a good guy.
When you talk to him and he's not an asshole south,
they're doing the right thing.
You need people like that.
Right?
Brian Fox,
magic bitches,
12 Fox magic t shirts.
Send them out there and then Peter,
Joseph and quotes.
I'm cool with the robots taking over.
That's how we're going to make you some money man.
Market you.
All right.
Um,
this is very cool conversation.
Is there anything else you want to say?
Is there anything that people need to know about?
Well,
shit,
there's tons of things I could say and tons of things.
I mean,
we got events coming up.
I'm going to be in New York.
If anyone's in New York at the end of this month in Colombia to hook up,
go for some drinks.
What is the best way to find out information?
What is your number one website?
I know it's,
it's Tz movement on those like guys movement,
[inaudible] movement on Twitter.
That's for the movement.
What is the best way to be informed?
What website can people go to?
May Movement side is just simply the zeitgeists movement.com and then the movie
side does zeitgeisty movie.com and then you can link to all the other sub sites
for the films and there's a bunch of scam sites that like they said like I guess
film series has been subject to more manipulation and scam and resellers.
I've been screwed over so extensive by attempting to be altruistic with the
distribution of that film.
People buy things from me,
resell it,
profit all over the place.
I just now stopped doing a lot of things I used to do after four years cause I,
I'm running out of money.
I can barely see myself making this new film.
It's going to be quite the quite the difficult venture,
but it's like just has attracted just about everything,
whether it's people that want to abuse it,
people that hate me,
people that like it does.
No,
no more strange phenomenon I've come across recently and in the Zike guys
phenomena.
As far as a cultural issue.
It's really strange and I'm just imagining it must be a pretty big life change
to go from just being a classical musician,
right?
To all of a sudden at the head of some crazy movement where you're being
critiqued and criticized for every single word that comes anyway,
probably were critiqued.
People gonna be mad at you for even doing this stupid show,
this ridiculous show.
We make fun of everything.
You know?
I think it's important to realize that we're all just people and no one should
take any of them said anyone that seriously.
I,
I have a great deal of humor with all of this.
I have the Carlin level,
I call it sitting on the sideline and that's something I don't readily admit,
but the Carlin level,
George Carlin is where you just don't give a shit anymore.
And as much as I push forward with all of this,
there's a side of me that says,
you know what?
It is what it is.
If myself,
if my partial,
excuse me,
if I become just deeply unhappy and he get tired of what I'm doing,
then I'm gone.
And it is what it is.
I'm not,
I don't owe anybody anything.
If people out there support such ideas,
they need to become their own leaders and really push this forward,
learn,
educate,
and do the same process that I had been doing.
There's nothing special here.
So there's anything I would leave to the audience that actually has an activist
bone.
It's that don't,
don't follow anybody.
You got to get out there and do it.
Cause a lot of these people that are at trying to lead,
if you will,
are not going to be around forever.
I could hit the car loan level and say,
fuck it.
Evolutionary called Osac goodbye humanity and I can go live on the moon
somewhere after I do something on the fly there
at the compound outside Sanoma,
the car,
the zeitgeists compliment their growing hippie pussy on trees.
Well,
thank you very much man.
As a very fun conversation.
Thank you.
I appreciate you.
That fascinating.
Um,
again,
uh,
all the information,
the zeitgeists movement,
the website is one more time,
the Zike guys,
movement.com and a Tz movement on Twitter.
And,
um,
and you're also have a Facebook page,
was a Facebook page,
like have an official on Facebook.
If you search that one.
This is like guys movement official.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
To the flashlight for all Chicago us.
No,
January 27th,
right?
Is that the next day?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's the Chicago theater.
There's still some tickets left.
Uh,
it's a,
a huge place.
It's going to be me,
Joey Diaz and Duncan Trussell and it should be a fucking blast.
And that's January 27th.
And,
uh,
I'm looking forward to that because that's the night after or the night before,
whether the UFC fights on Fox,
um,
is the show's sold out tonight.
Show sold out tonight.
But,
uh,
a friend of ours is a,
you know,
died in a car accident and was in a,
uh,
um,
he's in the other guys in the hospital.
It'll still,
yeah,
it's a famous,
a lot of people heard about it.
He's a standup comedian.
His name was Josh Myers
and there's a website,
donate a Angelo Bowers is the one that died.
Uh,
but yeah,
there's a website set up to that.
You can help Josh because he's going to be in debt for the rest of his life
because of all these,
I mean he's alive.
Thank God.
But,
but it's donate for josh.com if you can spare anything.
Thank you very much ladies.
Gentlemen,
thanks to the flashlight for sponsoring the podcast.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and were in the code name Brogan and you'll
get 15% off.
Number one sex toy for men.
Thanks to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement,
new mood,
the serotonin boosting five HTP supplement and shroom tech and shrimp tech sport
shroom tech,
immune to different mushrooms,
pop supplements that are all,
all the information is available on [inaudible] dot com and uh,
and why are 12 is the code to enter.
And if you enter that,
you will get 20 point 12% off until January 9th.
So go get some dirty bitches.
Thanks for tuning in.
Uh,
we will see you next week.
We've got a,
a bunch of cool people coming in and a good times ahead.
And as always,
we love all of you.
Dirty bitches,
all of you.
We'll see you tonight in the ice house chronical.
Yeah.
We'll see tonight in the icehouse chronicles.
That's right on the desk squad label.
It'll be on this,
uh,
this Ustream,
if you're watching on Ustream,
is same one on the Joe Rogan Ustream channel.
But if you were a on a iTunes,
it can only be found on the desk squad label on iTunes.
So subscribed to that shit.
Alright.
See a freaks.
Yeah.